this is a production of Cornell
University
welcome everyone to the 2022 campus
nature RX Symposium we are so excited to
have you
I am Stacy Parker with the UC Davis
Arboretum and public garden and my
colleague Haven cures it's her birthday
today and there are people she's she's
just outside this door and she is
um getting people saying hi to her not
realizing that we're doing a symposium
right now so she's supposed to be with
us we're really excited to have you all
here today
um
and
um very excited for the presentations
from our presenters we have so much
um that we're excited to learn about and
share with one another and so we're
we're very excited I see that haven has
has gotten your happy birthday from
heaven
and um
so we're going to keep our remarks
pretty brief here because we know that
the focus is really about uh getting
people
to the Pres presentations themselves we
do ask that everybody keeps themselves
on mute for the whole time unless you're
presenting we will be spotlighting the
Pres um the presenters feel free to have
your camera off we understand that you
know uh you probably don't want it on it
doesn't uh even if you have anything you
want to add no just that we're really
excited about doing this we've been
working hard on it we've got a great
lineup of speakers and it's just always
so much fun to bring this group of
people together because I think we're
all doing really cool things and I think
this is just such a good opportunity to
share what we're all doing and and you
know just just let other people know the
cool things that are going on so thank
you all for coming yes thank you so much
and
um in terms of uh the campus nature Rx
Network please feel free to visit our
website campusnature.com you'll see all
of the member organize there you can
learn how you would become a member
organization you'll be able to join the
newsletter there any information that
you uh want to explore learn about other
people's programs other
institutions that have campus nature RX
programs so it's all there but you can
also reach out to um uh particular
people that have a leadership role in
that Dorothy ebess and also Don Ray cow
Dorothy do you want to say a couple
words
foreign
thanks uh Stacy and Haven for all your
hard work
um yes so
um if you're interested in joining the
network membership is free
um you can subscribe to the newsletter
on the home page campusnature.com if you
go to the bottom of the home page if you
are an institution that has an active
campus nature program we uh if you fill
out an application form we can create a
web page for you to put on the website
as well add your institution information
and contact details so that people can
reach out to you directly if they come
across your page on our website so again
membership is free and we have you know
almost 50 or maybe more at this point
institutions that are officially part of
the network so we'd love to have you
join
um if you have more questions definitely
check us out on campusnature.com you can
always email me
um Dorothy ebis or DC ibes
wm.edu I'm happy to put that in the chat
if anybody interested so welcome
everybody today and thanks again Stacy
and Haven
thank you and thanks so much to Dorothy
and others who have put on this
Symposium before us because they created
a very extensive road map for us to be
able to do that was so helpful it was
essential and we may be asking some of
you to do that in the future so just
know that it was made as easy as
possible for us and it was a real treat
to actually be able to to help out in
putting this together so I'm just going
to advance a couple of housekeeping
slides here
um the first is the agenda for today and
as you can see there are three uh main
sections and presenters have been given
a total of 15 minutes for their sections
and we're gonna do our best to keep
everybody on time because uh we just
want to make sure that we keep this to
what we said set out for it to be
um and I think there'll be a couple of
breaks and at the end of each section
we'll have 10 minutes devoted to asking
the presenters their questions and for
those of you who are presenting please
know that we'll send a one minute
warning in the chat plus when another
message in the chat privately chat to
you letting you know that um that it's
that your time is up and then and then
if you go over I'm going to need to
interrupt so just be warned about that
okay
and then this slide is um to make it
really easy for you to get to
campusnature.com and to learn more about
becoming a member institution and how to
sign up for the newsletter and other
resources so
um the QR code takes you right to sign
up for the newsletter yes
thanks to Haven on that one okay so I
think that we're pretty good and
um oh this was our welcome slide so I
can't see the I don't have presenter
view here so I don't know what's up next
it's like a surprise to me but this was
um for us to just introduce ourselves
and this wonderful Symposium this year
okay so without further Ado I'm going to
hand it over to Dr Don Ray Cal and
Heather Culkin for um talking about the
nature RX guide for college students
thank you hi there I'm Heather Culkin
I'm the founder and director of families
in nature I'm based in Austin Texas
and I'm also the U.S co-chair of nature
for all which is a global movement to
connect people to Nature and and name
access to Nature as a human right and so
um
I would like to introduce you to
families in nature for a second we work
to inspire all families to fall in love
with nature all people to fall in love
with nature and to Foster the next
generation of conservationists
and we also work very hard to create
Equitable access to nature for all so
um and then my co-speaker in this
section is Dr Don Ray cow and he'll
introduce himself further but he is
heading up the nature RX program at
Cornell
the goal of our presentation and I'll
say this guide that we've created is to
help you see that nature is for everyone
and everyone needs nature it can be
really challenging to get outside to
play and spend time when you have busy
schedules or if you didn't grow up
spending time in nature with your family
or have a family that's spent a lot of
time outside
um if you don't feel like you belong
outside or in state and national parks
if you don't have a car at school to get
to places where nature seems to be far
away
or even if you've changed ecosystems and
it can be challenging to learn how to
play in the snow how to dress in the
North or how to be safe and still spend
time outside in the heat of August in
the southern states
and so Dr Rico and I wanted to create a
really simple and approachable resource
to help you see nature as something that
is all around you no matter where you
are it can even be in your dorm room
and definitely on your college campus
and so with the huge amount of help from
my program coordinator Jordan Jolly who
is also on this call
um she's monitoring the chat for you
guys
we have created this nature RX guide for
college students
we want college students we want to help
you guys get more nature into your lives
for Better Health mental and physical
health for school Success and for
happiness to enjoy your life and enjoy
your time at school
um
we've all had so much stress for the
last couple of years with covet a lot of
people have started college during covet
and online and in their parents houses
like my own children did and so it's
difficult right now and so the more time
we can help you spend in nature the
healthier you'll be and the better your
grades we even put in some things about
making friends outside so we hope that
this is a great resource for you guys to
feel that you can get outside more often
and have fun
and I'm going to take over from Heather
there and walk you all through this
guide but before I do that I want to
preface my remarks uh by saying a couple
of things first yes many thanks to my
colleague Heather
um and also to Jordan Jolly who took
took the initial text that I developed
and turned it into such a lively guide
uh Jordan has the benefit of being a
relatively recent college graduate
herself so understands how to make this
graphically appealing to today's 18 and
19 year olds
um we are going to put uh in the chat
how to access this guide for free
um but I will also mention that it can
be used today but it is also not cast in
stone so if you have suggestions for how
it can be improved Heather and Jordan
and I are very open to that
okay next slide
so we start uh with a table of contents
but more importantly we start by trying
to convince first-year students why
spending time in nature would be
important to them psychologically
physiologically
behaviorally and socially and hopefully
by reading through this list of benefits
of time in nature young people will see
that such activities first of all don't
have to take a lot of their daily time
and secondly can be of great great
benefit to them next
so we wanted to give
freshman uh sense of how they can spend
time outside while still attending to
their studies and to their various other
activities you can make sure that you
take a nature path when walking to class
you can eat your lunch or snacks outside
you can do your reading coursework or
studying outside and for so many of our
campuses today there are green spaces
where they can study and read and most
of those spaces especially when they are
nearby buildings have built-in Wi-Fi
next
we talk about the fact that spending
time in nature can save you money
because you can skip the gym you can
also select courses that involve the
outdoors that's not only really obvious
courses like biology ecology geology
environmental science but often
engineering courses cultural studies or
even writing courses will have outdoor
components
and you can also participate in
sponsored events that your college or
university are putting on
we do recognize that for many students
especially those coming from very
urbanized areas that spending time in
nature could be a fairly new and perhaps
even intimidating activity
so we suggest that individuals explore
the clubs that their school has to offer
outing clubs hiking clubs climbing
camping environmental science
sustainability clubs
Etc and these clubs can both be a great
way of engaging with nature and also
forming a social group
next
also we recognize that not all college
students are in the same Financial uh
conditions and that buying new outdoor
gear can be quite expensive so we have
recommendations for obtaining
second-hand gear which often is in
perfectly acceptable condition or
renting gear and we also talk quite a
bit about going with the seasons if you
are from Arizona and suddenly you're in
the state of Maine that can be quite a
shock and likewise if you're from New
York and now you're going to school in
Utah that can be equally disorienting
next
so we talk about the right sort of
activities for each season in Spring get
involved with planting visit farmers
markets go on a spring hike look for the
swelling of buds and the first spring
wildflowers and in summer find ways of
um going out onto the water and enjoying
the joys of Summer then in Fall next
slide
you can enjoy the Wonders and beauty of
the changing season pick produce uh
carve pumpkins and in Winter there is so
much to do for those of us who have a
cold winter sledding snowball fights
um and eating or drinking hot chocolate
next slide
so we also talk about the groups that uh
you can join or apps that you can
utilize next
and
um getting involved with Forest bathing
um finding a special sit spot where you
turn off your phone next
my time is up so we also talk about
dressing for the weather and we
encourage everyone to download this
guide
from the link that Heather has provided
and if you do have input about how the
guide can be made even better we invite
you to contact one of us with that thank
you
oh okay everyone
um we're gonna start our session one
thank you so much to Don and Heather for
that wonderful guide and uh for also the
invitation to everyone to help make it
better so
um we're going to turn it over to
Jennifer Roberts thank you
hi everyone hope you all can hear me
clearly
um I'm actually doing this presentation
from my hotel in Boston and I will be
leaving afterwards to go catch my flight
so
um I I'm so happy that this is our third
Symposium hopefully one day we will all
be together Outdoors doing this but in
any case I was tasked with um talking
about a new course that I've created
it's a new course that I've actually
started teaching this semester
um so it's brand new and I'm excited to
get the feedback from students so that I
can tweak it and you know make
improvements for the next go around the
course is called black bodies green
spaces from 16 19 till today next slide
please
um and so this is the cover of the ounce
page for the course and basically it
literally is what the title of the
course sounds like we go from
mostly in a sequential order from the
times when black bodies were brought to
what was to become the United States to
current day
um and next slide please and when we go
through all of these phases we actually
examine basically how the formation of
this country along with systemic racism
really shape the experience and the
connections of green space with black
Americans
um and so we go through a variety of
topics that I will kind of give you a
snapshot of
um momentarily but literally everything
from slavery and nature to all the way
to current day of situations of like
moving wild black so a lot of the work
that I do
um incorporates movement meaning
physical activity recreational or active
transport and often those activities are
done in Green Space or even blue spaces
or many different natural environment
spaces
uh next slide please
so I'm going to briefly talk about the
main course assignments and give you
kind of an idea of how I've created this
course and granted I think of this as
literally a living course no pun
intended but because I'm looking for
feedback from the students for things
that you know are working not working
and need to be tweaked next slide
so one of the activities that I have the
students do is a nature Journal so I
gave them all a hard bound journal with
their name affixed to it and they told
them this is a journal that I want you
to choose a space that you would go to
twice a week for the whole semester
because I want them to see the change
you know the change of the Season just
the change of the space on different
times of the day and different days and
I want them to reflect in that space and
it could be anything it could be
anything from you know writing a poem a
vignette or an essay or a drawing I've
seen some really wonderful drawings
um that some of the students have done
and I just kind of want them to be in
that space and engage in that space and
even if they don't have a lot to write
just really soaking up and absorbing
that and I've had some students who say
you know I really wasn't a natural or a
nature person but now going to these
this space I really look forward to it
next slide
um and so another assignment is a series
of three papers and with this assignment
I asked the students to really kind of
interrogate the concept of wilderness
and to look at the definition of
wilderness in terms of How It's been
defined through the lens of white people
from the beginning of time I want to
then then them to kind of critically
examine the relationship of how that
definition
um influenced the relationship of black
Americans with glitterness and then talk
about you know experiences of Oppression
or transgression within Wilderness
environments and I want them to do this
over three different historical periods
so the first paper is to do these
questions and write this essay within
the period of in Black Americans
enslavement the SEC is second is post
reconstruction and then the third is
modern times
next slide please
um another assignment is the
environmental justice interviews that I
want them to do so in pairs they are to
go and you know find an environmental
justice expert or someone who is an
environmental justice activist just
someone who works in that space and to
interview them you know interview them
and kind of ask them specifically how do
they define environmental racism and
what does it mean uh for environmental
justice what does that mean for people
of African descent today and then we
also had an activity in class where
students were allowed to we discussed
together what other questions would we
want to ask you know the interviews or
interviewees and so the students are now
at the point where I think it's this
week or next week that they're going to
actually do the interview and then they
bring in the recording
um well actually they post the recording
I only really get to see it but then
they do a presentation they talk about
their experience in terms of how this
actual ex um what they learned from this
interview
next slide please
and then the final project is the
Outdoor Apple project so this is not the
part that I have to tweak
um because I kind of when I was doing
this I kind of forgot these are like
undergrads and they may not have a car
so ask him to go like maybe all the way
to Shenandoah or all these places an
extra some outdoor afro activities are
kind of within the city but still it can
be our juice for a student who doesn't
have a car and you know and you know
they're they're on a fixed budget so
we've had tweak this and kind of go to
another uh amendment of this exercise
where they would actually just go to a
park and what I really wanted them to go
is to go into an outdoor afro event and
interview some of the people you know if
they were you know to get permission
interview some of the attendees at the
outdoor afro and ask them you know how
did you get involved in outdoor afro you
know have you always been connected to
Nature why or why not and you like your
most enjoyable aspects of Nature and
then anything else and then to take
photos of the people involved but also
the natural spaces so we're kind of
tweaking that a little bit and so the
students are probably going to go to a
close park that's kind of actually a bus
city bus ride away to do this activity
uh next slide please
so for these next series of slides
um you can just literally advance to
each slide like literally every five ten
seconds and this is really just going to
show you an example of some of the
lectures I have given in terms of the
whole framework of the class so we can
start advancing
so this is going all the way from the
beginning from the slave trade and then
from here we move and move forward and
go on to um you can go to the next slide
and we talk about forms of expression
while folks were enslaved for example
how African-American use
um natural elements to dye their clothes
this is a great documentary that we've
shown in terms of the Atkins Arboretum
and how that was a Plato role in the
Underground Railroad with Harriet Tubman
so that's a great piece that we've also
Incorporated next slide
um
we then talk about the engage or the
relationship of you know nature with
people who were not enslaved but up
North so we talk about Seneca Village
and we talk about how these folks use
nature as a way to kind of be removed
from like the toxic environment
literally from the discriminatory and
toxic environment but the physical toxic
environment within Um Manhattan next
slide
um we then also talk about the
relationship between Africans enslaved
Africans and Indigenous people and this
kind of
um then introduces us to the next slide
where we start to talk about land grants
and
um uh expropriations of land and what
that means in terms of you know the
tribal communities and then also we talk
about what does that mean in terms of
you know how do you atone for that how
do you recognize that particularly if
you're a land-grant university an
attendee of a land-grant university next
slide please
um so this is another example of um a
video restart I showed talking about the
tribal lands loss next slide
um then we move forward and we talk
about okay now folks are free you know
technically but not really because
they're still bound
um in terms of two uh aspects the Black
Codes in terms of how they their their
freedom was limited in the sharecropping
system so they're still working on the
land but they're in a they're
marginalized they're in a state of
Perpetual uh servitude also after this
period of this reconstruction they're in
this terrorized period of Jim Crow South
next slide please
and so we talk about what Jim Crow is
because a lot of these students they
didn't know the derivation of Jim Crow I
mean they kind of sort of knew they
thought it had to do with you know white
um uh water fountains and black water
fountains so they had a little bit of it
but they didn't get the under like the
whole history of it so we go through
that next slide please
we talk about how the um
slavery period as well as the
sharecropping really
um
exploited the lands as well as the
bodies black bodies in terms of you know
the sharecropping economy constantly
constantly how we went from tobacco to
continent but constantly constantly you
know causing ecological degradation to
the uh the soil all in the purpose of
making more money making more money
making more money we also talk about the
bow uh weavo
um uh infestation
um and that leads us to okay next slide
um that leads us also to you know
talking about environmental thought
leaders like just just George Washington
Carver how he was very instrumental in
helping Rectify that um Boll Weevil
infestation saying how you know we have
to change you know change
um the cracks you can't continuously
exploit the soil with the same type of
crop and so he introduced kind of like
planting peanuts particularly in that
Cotton Belt region next slide please
we also talk about Booker T Washington
how he talked about how you know yes he
was born an enslaved person and he
became free and he was instrumental in
uh the founding and the operation of
Tuskegee Institute but he talked about
using nature really for racial uplift
um I even played this um audio where he
often gave lectures to the faculty and
students every week at Tuskegee
Institute and this is a an audio that I
usually play for the students um it's
narrated by someone else but it's kind
of it's kind of quite powerful
particularly because it ends on that
last line nature draws no color line
next slide please
we also talk about the relationship of
nature within the perspective nature
among W.E.B Du Bois particularly we talk
about how he he found the irony in terms
of he found all this glorious physical
nature particularly when he went to the
national parks but in order to get there
he had to go in a Jim Crow car so he
talks a lot about that and then that
leads us to how he talked about next
slide please
um the um Idol would um so that was kind
of a self-segregate it's really I can't
really say self-segreated it was
segregated by you know by default
because he couldn't go to other Resorts
but how this Idol would um in Michigan
be claimed kind of like this black Eden
where black folks could go and
experience you know the natural
environment and actually W.E.B Du Bois
he had bought land there but he never
did you know erect uh a house or
anything but he he enjoyed going there
he thought it was just beautiful like a
black Eden next Story I mean slide next
slide
so then we also talk about how look you
know we had to get out of the Jim Crow
South we couldn't make money because we
were in servitude you know with the
sharecropping and it just was awful and
so we went and we went up north now to
urban areas next slide please and so
with this Great Migration six million of
African Americans with went to these
urban areas and one of them one of the
most popular along with Detroit in New
York City but with Chicago and so you
can see on this figure you can see how
initially in 1920 but you can't really
see feminists but initially 1920 black
Americans only were about five percent
of this tiny little swath of what is now
known as the Chicago Black Belt but by
1960 this whole area including the area
that's that says University of Chicago
was all completely African-American but
how they use that Washington Park which
they then subsequently named Booker T
Washington Park as a space for retreat
because they needed a green space like
you got to think about it these people
who went from working on farms working
outside to now the day starts not with
the Sun rising but with a Time clocking
industries and factories and now they're
like oh I'm you know I need a dose of
nature next slide please
we talk about particularly when we do a
little bit about talking about Richard
writing specifically because he talked
in black boy about his um Journey from
Memphis to Chicago next slide
um particularly since you know he had
that phrase the warmth of other Sons
hence that was a title that was in a
recent book recently but that was a
title he used for his black boy what he
talked about when he got to Chicago
there were no curves there were no trees
and so he was like you know what is this
he wanted to go for this new A New Hope
of life but you know there was there was
no trees next slide
uh let me talk about Sundown towns next
slide I know I'm running out of time and
I just you know we can end here but I'm
just giving you a kind of a snapshot of
all of the things we go through talking
about lynching you know we go next slide
we talk about Strange Fruit we talk
about all of these things about how
lynching terrorize people in natural
spaces and how that was something that
people have to kind of get themselves
reacquainted with because of the fact
that you know I heard about lynchings or
I saw lynchings in these natural spaces
so that's why I don't necessarily have a
connection
um and I can end here because I don't
want to take anybody else's time but
this is just kind of giving you a
snapshot of some of the classes that I
go through
wonderful thank you so so much Jennifer
sure wow
very powerful and that all of these
beautiful slides will be available the
recording of This Symposium will be
available to everyone
um
I think that we just have a little bit
of post-processing but we'll end up
putting it up on our website uh
yeah so thank you so much
okay next up uh we've got Everly Jazz
Jazzy
okay
hi
um
thanks
for that
um I'm Everly Jazzy and um I'll hold off
on introducing myself because I'm about
to tell you
um some of my story and after this I'll
um share how I started a campus RX
program at my University and some
strategies that might help some of you
who are thinking about doing this as
well next slide
um I grew up in Dayton Ohio where I
first fell in love with the outdoors
biking with my dad along
um a rail trail behind my house
um three miles to Dairy Queen often and
uh the trees and the grasses alongside
the path were my nature now next slide
now when I study nature and all of its
meanings and
um all of the differences of what
encompasses nature I think about that
bike trail and
how one's access and perception of what
nature is has many different forms
depending on where you grew up which
region of the world
um
you live in the access to different
flora and elements like mountains bodies
of water and more
next slide
and then when I went to University in
Washington DC I was exposed to a rich
tree counter canopy of the wealthiest
quadrant of the city and access to
nearby public lands and I learned about
a hiking Club
very similar to a
campus nature arts program at my school
I had not gone to
um I had not gone on many hikes prior
and it became evident that on my first
hike with the club The Parks of the
national national capital region are
really like true hiking trails and I
needed more experience
next slide
even though the entire group that I went
with on my first hike had to abandon the
hike solely because of my lack of proper
shoes and my nervousness about ice on
the trail I was really hooked I started
going on other walks and Hikes and even
became an outdoor ropes course
facilitator at my University
next slide
and then happen chance I became
president of an outdoor club at my
University
um the Jane Goodall roots and shoots
Club
with that opportunity I was able to take
others hiking and also camping for the
first time and it felt good to show
others the joys of spending time in
natural areas next slide
for the same reason I became a park
ranger in Wyoming and Alaska just one
year after camping for the first time in
my life and I also kept going
with my own personal love for the
outdoors so I
um one on a backpacking trip uh 1300
miles of the Pacific Crest Trail
um and I wanted to share my story and I
know we all have one because it shows a
perspective of the field that I don't
often hear I didn't grow up skiing in
the winters and sitting by a lake in the
Summers but I like all of us that have
been shown to still prefer natural areas
and the outdoors and I have this innate
preference for natural spaces and my
life has been changed because of my
connection to Nature
so it started from childhood but it
progressed with a campus
campus nature program
and I wanted to share this story because
I don't go to many conferences with
other practitioners or those doing more
applied work in the field and I wanted
to validate the work that all of you are
doing as well next slide
my journey wasn't easy but with these
programs and the grace and patience of
all of the more experienced hikers and
people who showed up along the way I was
able to overcome barriers where I could
have gotten lost or left out and then
when I started my Master's on nature and
health in Ohio State I wanted to do more
than just research I wanted to make an
applied difference
like the time when I was a park ranger
an outdoor educator I had heard of
nature RX and wanted to start a campus
RX program at Ohio State so
I wanted to reach out to to students and
especially students outside of my
environmental Focus department and
students who have faced barriers and
exclusion or constraints in outdoor
recreation and in their personal
experiences with natural space maybe
those who hold stigmas about or traumas
around the outdoors next slide
so not knowing where to start I emailed
the present of my University with my
plan and then I was able to receive some
response from the office of student life
and I met with the representatives there
to share my ideas and like possible
tiers of involvement
and then after a few follow-up emails I
was able to meet with a whole
Wellness panel
um with student life the counseling
office student health and others to
present my proposed program and though
everyone was on board it was difficult
to move forward just by myself without
this program being on anyone's top
priorities list and without the direct
support or funding from the University
so
in the end I had to graduate
from my program and leave things
unfinished and I never was able to hold
a proper series or offering
so I wanted to share some strategies
that I learned in my process so
hopefully anyone here who wants to start
uh campus nature RX program can overcome
these barriers and hopefully we can also
start a dialogue in the chat of any ways
that other individuals have overcome any
Hoops that they've encountered in
creating their program so I have three
to share
um next slide
thank you
so the first is partnering with someone
who is in charge of Campus priorities
and University resources this was really
helpful for me
um to meet with the office of student
life and to transcend just just one grad
student trying to create a project to a
network of heads of offices
and it was also
helpful to see who at the University was
interested in form a working group so
students professors staff members others
and Kinesiology psychology epidemiology
landscape architecture sociology
environmental and natural resources
might be a few that you seek out and
then once I formed a working group
although we never properly met we were
able to have like an online platform
where we communicated together and we
shared other other resources that each
other had and then strategize
and then also importantly is considering
equity and
underrepresented groups so
research has shown that those of low
socioeconomic status with education or
income and perhaps other marginalized
communities experience significant
benefits in nature once actually
recreating in the outdoors so research
from authors and that are actually in
attendance here have also shown that
there are significant benefits for
University students who have not already
had intentional experiences with quality
natural space for psychological or
health purposes and also reaching more
than just the nature focused student
population those who are already like in
Environmental Studies or plugged into
arboretums or campus Farms should be a
focus of all nature campus RX programs
so
it is also necessary to think about
actually like hiring or
um funding those who are skilled in
creating inclusive outdoor spaces to
form these programs in a manner that
will
um reduce barriers to outdoor recreation
and any like systemic like
discriminatory or
institutional exclusionary practices
culture-based stigmas and any concerns
or like inter intra personal needs that
individuals have like
um the right gear experience
um like like me when I had the
hesitations of walking on icy trails
with a drop into class five or six White
Water
um so also like offering beginner
beginner offerings or touch points to
build up to those trips as well next
slide
so I'm really passionate about this just
because I I think just like access to
higher education can facilitate some
financial and social Mobility I think
experiences and immersion in nature can
also provide healing to those who
um might have disparities in their
connections to
um less accessible natural spaces and an
outdoor education
making outdoor spaces and and around
college campuses more available and
Equitable with a variety of programs
like including walks but also like
sedentary and other kinds of activities
for all abilities and spreading
awareness of the importance of nature
connection and prioritizing within the
bureaucracy of Academia
this program and and the outdoors can
just help students who
um like me can enjoy and heal with
nature and perhaps rethink their entire
life stories thanks
thank you so much Everly that was so
inspiring
um I think we're ready for our next
speaker
Jesse Chang thank you
hi everybody my name is Jesse Chang I'm
the executive director of catalyst San
Gabriel Valley
which is a non-profit working in the
County of LA just east of the city of La
and our primary mission is partnering
with local school districts helping
underserved
schools families and students our
context is predominantly Asian Latino
families many of them who are also
recent immigrants and our goal is always
to not only see these families and
communities and schools not survive
but also Thrive and so School Gardens
has been one of the things that we've
been doing over the years and it's kind
of it's really a literal manifestation
of the kind of thriving we want to see
in our community and I'm rather new to
the whole nature RX piece
um and I think part of that is because
uh you don't talk about at least when I
was doing these Gardens uh I don't sell
the gardens as a place for for mental
health you know mental health and
well-being because uh to in order to to
kind of get the stakeholders and
administration on board we have to talk
about being an outdoor classroom this is
going to enhance the education the
science the maybe the writing so we
don't really talk about mental health as
a way of of creating these spaces
however I I did start becoming a
lecturer for a food environmental
justice class at Cal State University
Los Angeles
and so it's been interesting where I can
actually assign nature RX as part of the
curriculum and I've had students you
know respond positively to that as well
but at the K-12 level that's not
something I can necessarily dictate as a
non-profit partnering with local schools
but to just kind of next slide just to
give some context as to sort of the
motivation this is my this is a Google
map picture from 2019 of my childhood
home in Massachusetts
and it looks pretty much the same they
still kept the uh the sugar Maples in
the front
um this is giving me this is triggering
me because I remember I had to like rake
all those leaves up every fall
um but if you look in the back there's
also very much uh um there still is a
remaining Uh Wood Woods in the back and
there was even more when I was growing
up because they didn't have as many of
the sort of these suburban houses kind
of you know eating away at all the
forests and I remember have very rich
memories every year looking for wild
blueberries in the patch of grass where
you know the grass wasn't able to grow
um searching for salamanders underneath
logs Every Spring looking for the the
Vernal stream or Wetland that would
appear with the snow melt or with the
rains and seeing the emergence of skunk
cabbage and looking for pink lady
slipper orchids uh every uh Every Spring
you know creating a little forts a lot
of logs and so all of these things uh
were such a I I never realized like the
gift of that amount of exposure to
Nature you know and I wasn't supervised
either no that was the other thing
um but that that kind of Rich experience
I think you can go to the next slide uh
is is what I what I feel especially here
in urban Los Angeles is what I always
want to pass on to my kids who are
growing up here in LA
and what I would like to see especially
are underserved schools uh to be exposed
to as well I'm going to give you a
second just to read this quote from
David Sobel who's a place based educator
and uh you know teacher about
place-based Environmental Education
give you five seconds to read that
and the context of this quote is and my
daughter has a
um confirmed this that Environmental
Education when she was in elementary
school basically was teaching them about
global warming and um you know all the
all the terrible things that are
happening to our planet
and uh David Sobel saying like you know
when we when we start with that uh that
can actually create a subtle form of
dissociation uh for for children
especially if they haven't had very a
lot of positive experiences with nature
then what they're learning about nature
is that it's it's all going you know
badly and therefore it's also
overwhelming and therefore is sort of
like well we need to kind of leave it
behind uh and there's nothing I can do
about it
um and so I really like how David Sobel
says no the first step we want to do is
to create a sense of love you know can
we talk about love learning to love
um love it and feel comfortable in
nature and I think that's kind of my
primary motivation is to to create these
spaces on these campuses where a lot of
students don't get that kind of exposure
I remember one of the superintendents
when we were talking about one of the
projects things yeah I want my kids you
know I want our students to have that
same kind of access
to the kinds of green space that you
often have to pay for or have
memberships to get into like the
Arboretum the local arboretums uh or
other Gardens uh in La
um and so I think that's one of those
things yeah we want to create have
create access with these Gardens but
more importantly not just create the
access but also create a sense of
bonding and create a sense of connection
to nature for students who are not
necessarily exposed to a lot of it
especially in our context in La next
slide so I'm going to talk about two of
the gardens one of them is a high school
edible Native Garden here in um those
are two of my interns
and uh you can go to the next slide
and the other ones uh Middle School
nature garden this was primarily natives
and then next slide
and as I was reflecting on this this
talk I was like well what made this some
of this unplanned nature RX that
teachers implemented uh you know how
what made that uh successful and part of
it was the geography of where we placed
these Gardens and as you can see from
these kind of Google Maps uh the red is
where the gardens are located in terms
of where the campus are and you can see
that they're they're in central
locations they're not marginalized like
put off to you know I remember walking
through some sites and they really want
you know the principal or the you know
they want to put a way in the back like
in the back corner you know out of sight
out of mind
um but I think that that kind of would
end up not being utilized because people
aren't going to see it and only those
who have that kind of special knowledge
or or have like you know particular
passion for it will maintain it
um and so these Central locations on
campus gave that sort of access and you
can see the blue lines are where the
students and um School Community parents
they would all be walking through those
different areas the one on the right
hand side in particular the nature
garden uh those there were four or five
doors that actually open up on each side
of each of those two wings and so those
doors actually open out into the garden
and students can actually walk through
students and teachers can actually walk
through there and so and then the t is
where the the sort of my Champion
teachers who really uh cared for the
garden and integrated the garden into
this into their classroom you can see
where they're also centrally located
and so they have a media access to the
garden
okay
um next slide
and so here's a quote from the high
school teacher English teacher I'll just
give you a second to read what she had
and it was funny because again this was
unplanned this is just ways that she
started incorporating the garden uh into
uh her classrooms and she said for
herself that personally I'd always go
outside to decompress
um get away from technology she had a
lot of
um computers set up in her in her
classroom that you know was adjoining to
the garden
uh get away from technology and sit in
the garden to feel better
I was also a reminder for me to get out
more now she's no longer at that at that
school no longer having access to that
garden and she notices that um she's a
lot more stressed at her new her new
location
okay next slide
uh this is the the junior high science
teacher let me give you a second to read
what he had to say
and and I've been in and walked in like
during his uh during his classes and I
can attest that that classroom
environment can be very stressful for
you know at times you know classroom
full of Junior High kids
um and but yet you know he was able to
utilize the garden for
um for students to be able to stress uh
he noticed they were happier when they
were working outside
um
and
yeah so that's one of those uh so when I
even though this was unplanned I was
really happy to hear about how
um nature uh and these Gardens were
being utilized to to address things like
mental health and help students uh and
I'm hoping that uh when I started the
lecturing for the food environmental
justice class I started online it was
completely online because we were still
coming out of the pandemic but I think
now you know maybe that's part of the
Silver Lining I'm hoping that nature RX
will continue to not just happen in
these Gardens but as I'm building more
Gardens and I'm looking to do the same
at Cal State LA uh that in our
post-pandemic world that nature RX is
just going to become another way of
intentionally selling more school
Gardens in our underserved communities
and LA's Urban concrete sprawl so thank
you for your time
okay
that was so lovely I mean
wow I'm just so excited about all of
these presentations thank you so much
Jesse that was wonderful
okay so
um without further Ado I'm going to
um hand it over to the next group here
we've got uh para Sabo
application
flat bike I'm not I'm sorry
introduce yourself and then also your
students thank you
uh so hello everybody my name is Nina
stoyan Rosen swag and I will be
um kind of overseeing I'm not doing the
actual presenting in the first session
from a two-part talk by uh uh folks from
the University of Florida so uh Dr Sabo
Atwood will be presenting in session two
and uh three first-year medical students
Angelica chalungari akanksha Dave and
Annika Liu will be presenting the first
talk uh that is part of a project that
has been developed with the assistance
of a fellowship from the Harvard Macy
Institute
so it looks like and with that I will
turn it over to Angelica
okay hi everyone
as Dr you mentioned my name is Angelica
first year medical student here at UF
um
sorry okay
um I think my other colleagues are here
as well but just to kind of start us off
um so again as Dr Nina mentioned in this
presentation we're kind of going to be
exploring kind of the ideas of
University art museums it's healing
natural spaces uh and specifically we're
going to be kind of discussing a program
that was created with this in mind
um and so before I kind of delve into
that idea those ideas I should first
mention that this program was developed
with the help of the art museum-based
Health Professions fellowship with the
Harvard Macy Institute
um
and just so what is this program so
essentially what this program is is it
works to kind of use contact with art
especially you know kind of the
metaphorical nature that one can
experience through ART to assist you
know students medical students health
professional students
um and you know eventually patients with
becoming kind of familiar with and
comfort trouble with being in nature and
so in conjunction with the University of
Florida's Samuel P Han music art which
is kind of depicted here this project
stores art museums and art as kind of
like these neutral spaces uh for
exploring
um sort of people's Comfort safety and
preference for further interaction with
nature in other spaces let's go to the
next slide
okay and so you know again as I
mentioned this project recognizes kind
of nature is sort of this broad healing
modality and so I want to note
particularly
um that within this project we Define
nature very broadly so we include you
know even small nature so you know like
snails to larger organisms like the hawk
here
um to even your habitats and possibly
kind of Wilderness Area so nature is
very broad with how we're defining it
here okay so you know this idea of
nature prescription programs you know as
kind of learned through all these other
presentations as well is not new
um you know for example as I've listed
kind of here
um there are you know websites such as
parkrx where
um patients can kind of retrieve
information about uh their local parks
um there are programs like walk with the
dock where you know physicians may lead
you know kind of group walks with their
patients and therefore kind of create a
safe environment for their patients who
might be you know comfortable with the
nature or fearful of nature
um there has also been you know
rheumatologists for example uh also
write prescriptions for their patients
to repot plants which can be especially
beneficial to patients that have
arthritis or patients that want to might
want to maintain kind of their motor
skills so that's a useful way of
engaging in nature and also engaging in
kind of that physical activity as well
um here at the University of Florida we
also have a Horticultural Therapy
Program where essentially patients with
specific medical diagnoses can benefit
from things like gardening or specific
outdoor activities
um and you know groups in general have
also created kind of like these medical
prescription pads
um where you know Physicians or other
Healthcare professionals can prescribe
different nature activities
explain
okay
um hi everyone my name is akanksha Dave
I'm also the first year medical student
um so kind of going off of what Angelica
was saying about nature prescription
um here on this slide you can see that
we've provided kind of from the Shetland
Islands a program that shows part of a
nature prescription
um and so I don't know if you can you
know read specific things on the on this
slide but essentially there are annual
calendars that offer a choice of outdoor
activities in specific areas so things
like it's November right now so things
like um according to the calendar going
otter watching or talking to a Pony
um kinds of things like this could help
patients um be more in tune to what is
available to them locally
um and help make
um interacting with nature
um more accessible for them
next slide
um so this is an example of a calendar
that offers seasonal outdoor activities
in the game still area which is weird
we're located in the University of
Florida
um and so as you know healthcare
provider talking through such a calendar
with some of these activities can also
help
um someone prescribe nature activities
to their patient and it can also with
the variety of activities
um
help
the patient determine what kinds are
would be most beneficial or intriguing
for them
um so activities such as walking
something as simple as that or even more
interesting such as birding or shell
collecting
you're catching
um kind of
can help
appeal to a wide variety of patients
um next slide please
okay
um and so our question here is is nature
always inspiring safe and accessible
um so because we know that contact
nature may not always be safe accessible
or comfortable for all
um you know sometimes some of us take it
for granted that it is so accessible and
inspiring which is not the case for
everyone so some individuals for example
may have grown up in urban areas and not
had a chance to
um
move comfortably and interact with
nature
um or they may have like specific
preferences for the kinds of nature like
um referring a beach environment versus
a forest
um because of like the experiences and
the type of nature that they've had um
maybe they've grown up in an area that
are that is often hit by like hurricanes
um and so in that case maybe
um an environment like a forest could be
considered more threatening to them
because there would be Danger from
things like pollen trees
um and so there could also be like fears
of specific animals that like live in
those environments
um things like you know spiders snakes
um nature can seem violent if those
predators are common
um where they can feel or nature can
also feel unsafe if you know the
Predators are larger potentially
dangerous
um and kind of going on to
um group experience so particular groups
um such as the black indigenous people
of color or by POC Community
um may have had and may continue to have
negative experiences in outdoor areas
for example some of those groups may
have been excluded legally
um in the past let's say for example Jim
Crow laws
um some of those groups may be made to
feel you know uncomfortable and face
aggressions and so they may feel
physically threatened in certain outdoor
areas
um and so those groups that have those
limited outdoor experiences
um obviously have not had the chance to
develop Comfort outside and those
stereotypes that kind of
um
follow them limit the opportunities to
experience the outdoors and develop
those those skills so they can be become
more comfortable outside
um
so outdoor areas also
um can be inaccessible in terms of
distance and cost
um those are like economic reasons
um
nearby outdoor areas also might not be
safe again depending on the environment
although they may become safer if they
are accessed in groups or
um with with people who have higher
skill levels and finally
um interests so an individual specific
interest May mean that the local nature
around them is not as enticing for
example
um we live in Florida so maybe rock
climbing is not as possible in Florida
or some if you live somewhere it's
landlocked you know the ocean is might
be hundreds of miles away
next slide please
hi I'm Annika I'm a med student
um so a concher brought up some issues
regarding the accessibility of the
accessibility of healing and nature
um and as a solution this project
proposes using curated nature such as
Gardens especially in museums that can
offer opportunities for safe contact
with nature next slide please
so on the cover slide Angelica
introduced the Samuel P harn Museum of
Art which is uf's Art Museum and it has
a number of garden spaces and it always
has new and exciting resources
um so in the next few slides I will be
showing works of art whether From The
Heart Museum some are not
um and I want you to think about how
they make you feel and what images are
most appealing to you
um so many of these works of art in the
new doted collection depict Florida
nature and outdoor spaces some images
might be recognized as safe and
comfortable While others depending on
the individual and their experiences can
be more challenging and uncomfortable so
this variety of perspectives can offer
numerous opportunities
next slide please
um so in some nature once removed and
metaphorical
um or nature in art can be a means of
accessing of recognizing safe nurturing
comfortable and healing outdoor
environments
next slide
and so this project uses images of
nature to allow individuals to explore
how they feel about nature and natural
areas to find what resonates with them
next slide
and finally this project explores ways
of engaging with that metaphorical
nature to help recognize and imagine
entry into a healing space
next slide please
um yeah so here's just some more works
of art
um and really think about how these make
you feel
um and also what our most appealing to
you and it can vary based on the
individual based on experiences based on
likes and dislikes it's a lot of
perspective and preference
next slide please
um so earlier I discussed metaphorical
nature which is basically nature that's
been removed
um
from actual nature and it's depicted in
art so you can avoid uh certain triggers
that a Congress has mentioned
um certain dangerous animals or
um negative experiences and once that's
removed we do have metaphorical nature
and thus it generates a safer space it
gives you a lot of variety in a museum
you have a range of choices and within a
museum or within General metaphorical
nature you also have the opportunity to
explore images and spaces
next slide please
um okay so just to kind of cap it off I
know that we're kind of running a little
bit low on time here
um but essentially you know again we are
kind of exploring this idea of using art
museums as metaphorical
um nature and kind of engaging students
medical students and especially patients
eventually with that
um and so when thinking about kind of oh
um when I'm just going to go say really
quickly but these are kind of just like
some opportunities that we've listed
here
um for different Art Museum encounters
um and so these are potential ways that
we can kind of continue to engage you
know students patients and becoming
comfortable with art
thank you
yeah okay so I'm gonna I just have about
five minutes left here so I'm gonna whiz
um through these slides but I think I
can get the idea across so this is a
picture I always like to start with and
and I'm Tara Sable Atwood by the way so
I'm I'm fairly new to this space
um I'm actually the chair of the
Department of Environmental Global
health and run the wellness programs at
University of Florida
um but really got interested in this
connection between uh nature and health
and wellness a few years ago and been
really influenced by conversations with
Don and Nina and and others so really
pleased to be here
um so this is a the picture that I
always start with because it makes me
feel
um something for sure and I'm probably
biased because that's actually my
daughter
um but it always reminds me that if a
five-year-old can be in the moment and
be inspired by Nature so so can I
um so I always start there next slide
please so what I thought I would do
today is just like give you a little
snippet of uh what's going on here at
University of Florida with respect to
Green spaces and a prescription program
that I've been involved with in the
greater Gainesville Community so here's
an aerial view of Shan's hospital so we
have pretty big hospital here at Shands
and the outlined area there
in white the white outline has actually
been turned into a
Green Space some people call it a
healing Garden for children next slide
please
and I don't have a lot of pictures for
for time but essentially this is the the
design and there's been a lot of people
that have worked really hard on
putting lots of different thoughtful
spaces together there in conjunction
with the Horticulture folks and several
others that were just mentioned
um that is up and and running and and
open it's open to everybody but it
certainly has a focus on kids with the
idea that children will be prescribed to
use the garden as part of their health
care plan in the hospital and that's
actually an initiative that got stole by
covid but it's picking back up starting
in December of this year
so I was involved in a little bit of a
different aspect on that project that I
won't go into today but when we got
started in thinking about prescribing
the use of Green Space to these children
you know we thought about well how could
we sort of extend that behavior once
they were not in the hospital any longer
and so we started looking at where the
children were discharged to and that's
sort of the aerial map over on the the
right hand side
um and then how could we maybe do that
so next slide please
so we got engaged with a program many of
you probably know about which is kids in
parks and and track trails
and essentially this is driven by
um kids in Parks is the organization and
they help folks design uh self-led
Adventures it's it's kid focused for
sure
um where it gets them Outdoors you know
that's essentially the the goal here and
they do that in a lot of different ways
and then there's a second level on that
which is they can actually be prescribed
to use the trails as part of the the
program next slide please
so the kids and Parks has about 180 plus
or minus a few
um track trails that are Across the
Nation you can see where a lot of them
are are clustered uh we now have the
first three in Florida that are here in
Gainesville which are fully operational
now we have a couple others that are
going in in South Florida now as well
next slide please
one of the neat aspects about track
Trails is they keep track of how many
children are actually using the trails
and they do that because the methods are
incentivized so if they complete the
Little self-led Adventures which are
through brochures
they can log in to a portal and then
they get Badges and other sorts of
prizes for doing it but at the same time
the company's actually collecting
information about who's using the trail
and when and so forth
um so we
set out to do this
um to incorporate a few other Trails
um in the communities of Gainesville
like I said there's three of them you
can see sort of the questions that we
wanted to ask can we take small doable
steps to enhance existing parts in
Gainesville as an inexpensive and
enjoyable way for people to tap into the
positive health effects of natural
settings can we broaden how the public
values parks to include seeing them as a
Public Health Access asset excuse me and
can we impact Health outcomes through
sustained use of the trails and so
that's sort of a research piece that I'm
interested in that I won't talk too much
about today next slide
so again going back to the the where
patients are live essentially
um that
are at Shan's hospital
we had a whole sort of framework for how
we wanted to decide where the trail
should be and that was definitely one of
the driving factors but then of course
we had to consider lots of other things
like you know accessibility and and so
forth
um and so that's what we did next slide
and so what's included in these trails
are a Trailhead sign essentially and
then you can see below the brochures and
again these are very focused on younger
children and so an adventure might be
you know there's a hide and seek one
where the kids have to sort go through
nature and you know observe and reflect
and you know check off that they found
found something or answer a question
about something
um and so they're pretty neat and
they're really tailored so you work with
kids in Parks so they're completely
tailored to the setting and the the
Flora and Fauna or whatever else you're
interested in that's particular to that
area so it was really fun working with
Park and Recreation and Horticulture
folks and so forth to to figure out how
we should design these Adventures
next slide
and so I think just to wrap up here
because I'm I'm at time is you know
thinking about campus RX programs you
know could we use this sort of model
um to create some type of Campus RX
program obviously for for older
individuals or to include older
individuals
um but could we then use this network in
some way to expand their access to
Nature off campus as well so sort of
creating what I'm calling this
community-based network
um so the activity doesn't always have
to be totally centralized on on campus
so I'll stop there I'm out of time and
and thanks for the opportunity today
perfect thank you so much this was
fabulous uh what a wonderful
wonderful presentation set of
presentations that we've had this
morning
um thank you all so much to our speakers
we are so fortunate to have them and
this brings us to our 10 minutes for
question and answers for any of our
previous presenters unfortunately ex
with the exception of Jennifer Roberts
who had to catch a plane which many many
thanks to Jennifer for making the time
for us this morning that she did before
she had to go
so
um what we're going to do is we actually
have a volunteer Jordan Jolly has um has
offered to
um
monitor the chat for your questions and
pose questions to any of our speakers
that we've had this morning so
can any of the panelists discuss funding
options or opportunities that can help
launch nature RX programs thank you to
all that's from Linda
I would just say um part of the design
and the way things were designed was to
try to work with very limited Financial
Resources so that we didn't have to find
um
funds
at least for the project that that
Angelica Annika and akanksha described
I think that's the question that
everybody wants an answer to but
I I agree that's
even with the awareness of mental health
like
um and even funding for it uh in the
K-12 level uh I think a garden would
probably seem like a stretch
um so
we're you know installing at least from
my perspective it's like it's still it
still might be a stretch and so you have
to kind of
get it in another way and then
um and then see if you can incorporate
um those elements
you know we've been talking about
um because some of our stuff's in the
community as as well kind of the
community science programs where you
actually get
you know individuals in the community
um on board
um which doesn't really cost anything
except your time to manage them right
um so that's one of the things we've
been really throwing around a lot with
trying to advance at least the Track
Trail programs and there's been quite a
good bit of interest in that so kind of
a a way around and trying to get
you know at least some of the labor part
of this
um and then it's great Community
engagement as well so there's a lot of
benefit all around to that
yeah one thing I was going to mention is
um
really getting to know your Community
Partners and other orgs and other folks
that are in your communities that are
doing uh similar work and that might
have resources to share or to
collaborate with you
um like free seeds like going back to
that Garden piece or discounted or free
access to certain Parks spaces or areas
that may cost
um and so just kind of seeing seeing
what your network has to offer as well
and let's see you know I would just like
to quickly add that in the nature RX
book uh that I co-authored we talk about
the fact that at colleges and
universities there are so many
individuals who are willing to volunteer
their time to the effort uh after all
they're already receiving salaries so
um at Cornell and at so many of your
campuses uh we've been able to establish
nature RX programs with very little
money
and then let's see could we learn more
about how to set up a local program with
kids in Parks any sense they might be
interested in working on college
campuses
I haven't broached that with them yet
um
you know and they they very well may be
open to the idea I just don't know but I
will say working with them in general
was very easy you know and I think
they've done so many of these Trails now
that they actually have a process and
they have seven steps and how they they
do it
um but their trails are very diverse you
know some of them are in schools some of
them
are in Parks you know some of them are
downtown in Washington DC you know
they're they're very different versions
um and it it really is whatever you want
the quote sort of Adventures to be is is
what they are and they help you get
there so
um yeah I haven't actually asked them
about that yet
anybody else want to add to that
okay we have has your guide been
launched how do you introduce students
to it feedback from students and users
thus far
so either either Heather or I could
respond to that one
um the guide is ready to use we had put
in the chat
um how to link to it and download it and
as I mentioned in my remarks it's ready
to use right now
um
but also
um it is open to being edited and
refined so if people do download it and
they have suggestions for ways to
improve it we are very open to that
and then it looks like Heather posted
the link to the guide again in the chat
so you're welcome to access that
download that and use that as you would
like
um let's see
so not much feedback so far because it
is so new so we would appreciate all the
feedback you have to give
um both aesthetically and content wise
let's see I'm working with a student to
start a student organization on campus
the organization then becomes eligible
for funding from the University for two
hundred dollars per year
we want to reach students who don't have
transportation or means to explore
nature away from campus but we also plan
to use campus and green spaces and blue
spaces too oh sorry not a question but
Austin work Christy and a great answer
to a previous question that was asked
earlier about funding and getting
students on campus
um some libraries have seed libraries
for Gardens Nina mentioned also a lot of
libraries now are implementing gear
share or outdoor education and learning
materials that you can check out like
backpacks full of like observational
tools
um nature journals that kind of thing so
check out what your local libraries have
to offer
so actually that's perfect training for
this for us so we just uh came to the
end of our question and answer SEC
session for the first
um a session of
of the Symposium and um so I just want
to once again thank all of our speakers
that was incredible
um once again all of this all of their
slides will be posted as well as a
recording of the Symposium and
um on the campus nature website and many
of our speakers are also willing for us
to reach out to them directly with
questions that that you may have about
their programs in the future so
welcome back
to the 2022 nature RX Symposium third
annual
um we are about to start on our second
session section I think we called them
oh sessions we call them session sorry
um called creative collaboration so all
of the speakers are going to be speaking
to
um collaborations that they've had in um
with affiliated with their nature RX
programs and I'm actually going to be
the person to start us off so
um and forgive me I am getting over a
little bit of a cold here so
um you can see that I will be followed
by Dorothy ebis and then also Ashley
Hinton of the University of Kentucky
so
um without further Ado I'm gonna get
started
so welcome everyone thank you again for
being here today
um my name is Stacy Parker and I'm with
the UC Davis Arboretum and public garden
my talk today is aimed at those starting
new programs in particular but also I'm
hoping that established programs will
also be able to glean some new insights
or ideas as well
I'm going to share how accessing the
power of collaboration has resulted in a
campus-wide nature RX initiative at UC
Davis called healthy outside
so before I get into the details of the
healthy outside initiative I'd like to
start with a quote we often use at the
Arboretum and public garden and is also
the basis for my talk today
start where you are use what you have do
what you can by art Arthur Ashe
this has been incredibly helpful for us
when we are first starting out with a
new program or project and I will walk
you through what this meant for us
specifically in terms of developing our
nature RX program and in particular the
campus-wide
healthy outside initiative what I will
say is that for those of you looking to
start a new nature RX program at your
school from scratch the good news is
that you may already have one
you just haven't been calling it back
so start where you are for the Arboretum
and public gardens starting where we
were in terms of of launching a nature
RX program meant looking around to say
to see where we were on the road in
achieving that aim
so the great part about this step is
that we found and I suspect many of you
will find too is that we had already
traveled pretty far down that road in
our nature RX Journey without even
knowing it in other words looking around
the Arboretum and public garden already
has an incredible volunteer program an
incredible student internship program
called learning by Leading which some of
you may have heard of or even have
started learning by Leading programs of
your own and we also have public
programs Outreach events and garden
Collections and interpretation all
designed to connect people to plants and
nature in one way or another
so taking stock is pretty fun because it
allows for you to see all that you have
you have already at your disposal
including staff as resources in that aim
as well
so it turns out that we already had a
pretty robust an hrx program to start
like I said we just weren't calling it
that
so that was a fun Discovery and I
suspect
likewise will be the same for many of
you
so the next step is to use what you have
and we at the University are lucky
enough to have the Brain Trust of the
University at our fingertips so as you
can see there are many many logos here
for UC Davis administrative and academic
departments all of which uh here are are
those that we have been able to partner
with and one of the exciting aspects of
working with the university is that
there are experts in their fields around
every corner so whether it's bird
experts fish biologists experts implant
and insect interactions
um professional photographers or
Communications and marketing
professionals experts in sustainable
agriculture or our campus planners
um sustainability experts our grounds
and Landscape managers including campus
arborists experts in public health and
meditation so the university is is
basically a small city of people who
make the place run so drawing on those
with the expertise to do that or those
that are here teaching and conducting
research in more specialized Fields such
as Earth Sciences Native American
studies animal Sciences Etc there's just
no shortage of opportunity for
partnership
and one of the major perks for us of
course is that we don't have to pay them
and that was mentioned a little bit
earlier
um when when somebody was asking about
funding
is that
um because we because we don't have to
pay them we don't have to fundraise in
order to host these programs many if not
most of these experts have a component
of their jobs that requires some degree
of public service or Outreach so the
other point that I also want to make is
that when you're asking people to
participate in Sharing what they're most
passionate about it tends to result in a
pretty compelling program and a feeling
that you've had a behind the scenes look
into their field
and I also want to point out a resource
here called healthy UC Davis and
um we're pretty lucky to have that at UC
Davis
um so arguably the healthy outside
initiative may never have come to be had
we not had that group so healthy UC
Davis is an interdisciplinary group
composed of staff faculty and students
dedicated to making UC Davis UC Davis
the healthiest place to work learn and
live and the steering committee of this
group is the engine for collaboration
within the realm of health and
well-being on our campus so without this
group of people it would have been much
harder to accomplish
and I know that some other institutions
also have similar steering committees I
know that there's one at Cornell for
instance so uh my advice you know like
as such is to find or build a similar
group at your own institutions to do the
same many of you uh may already have
bodies already designed for this such as
mental health task forces I advise you
to insert yourself word as Gardens
um so so we're a public garden if you're
a public garden program too
uh you may not seem like the obvious
choice but with nature RX we really
broaden the the
um conversation around mental health and
well-being and leverage the outdoors of
the campus as a resource
um
so once you've gathered an idea of what
you're going to have for to use for
building out your nature RX program in
terms of identifying collaborative
Partners the next step is to do what you
can
so um in setting out to create the
healthy outside initiative we realized
that first we needed a web page we
started by creating a web page on the
healthy UC Davis website including
Gathering and organizing healthy outside
resources from all of our campus
partners and then we lumped them into
three categories that you'll see here
move outside restore outside and grow
outside
we created a healthy outside resource
map and also a healthy outside calendar
so events that fell into the category of
healthy outside could be highlighted on
our page
and once those resources were all in
place then we uh needed a way to promote
the initiative so uh which led us to
creating a campaign and we're on a
quarter system here at UC Davis so we
chose Spring quarter to hold our
campaign and quarters are 10 weeks long
so that's how long our campaign was and
we realized that in order to get people
to participate we need some kind of
incentive
so we started drawing on all of our
partners in healthy UC Davis to chip in
any swag that they had related to being
healthy outside
so you can see ours uh swag bag on here
and then also once again these are all
the specific campus partners that we
drew upon for this campaign
um the swag bag had a lot of goodies
such as water bottles water bottle
slings and an arboretum and public
garden tote bag a reusable straw a
picnic blanket
um
cutting board there were lots of really
wonderful things so so that was really
exciting because once again this was uh
just about reaching out and seeing who
could donate 10 of these items basically
for the duration of our campaign and so
so no money once again all donated
so then the next thing that we had to do
was to determine what people had to do
in order to be entered into a drawing
for the prizes this meant coming up with
rules a structure how we would manage it
um
etc for how it would all work and then
creating a page
um to publish all of this information
along with the supplemental publicity
materials so we decided to have people
share photos of themselves doing
something healthy outside and answering
a couple of questions so they could do
this through a Google form or they could
also do it through social media on
Instagram
and the the questions that they answered
were how to stay healthy outside
oh how they
what they do to stay healthy outside
themselves and then also why they think
it's important to be healthy outside and
then we called these testimonials
and
um submitting one of these actually uh
was basically your raffle ticket for
being
um entered into the drawing
so then the the testimonials started
pouring in and we were quite happy with
the results we had maybe over 350
throughout the campaign
um
we were
um we also had a colleague in our
Communications unit so talk about
collaboration that kept adding them to
the web page as the weeks went by
and also highlighting the winners
um
entry
we also specifically reached out to our
campus leadership as you will see
pictured here in the middle
and we have their answers posted I
wanted to get more photos in so you
could see more of the photos so you
don't see the um the answers for these
other folks but you can see uh like a
little sampling of the submissions with
these photos so it's really really sweet
and very touching how many people
participated and uh and there was no
um limit to how many times that you
could enter
okay so I also wanted to mention that
while we were working on this larger
steering committee
um well like a actually it was a small
team of the larger steering committee
um members of the healthy UC Davis on
this larger campaign I was also
directing our programs at the Arboretum
and public garden to be aligning up into
delivering on this effort of healthy
outside
um so you'll actually see from this
slide several photos of Partnerships
that the Arboretum and public garden had
with classes and student artists in our
art department and our design Department
so once again the power of collaboration
allowed for us to host these wonderful
student works of art in the Arboretum at
a time when our staff were at capacity
basically trying to rebuild from the
impacts of covid and these
collaborations are incredibly positive
for all parties involved obviously our
visitors loved them and with a minimal
effort primarily coordination Logistics
and support on our part we were able to
host these interesting and exciting art
installations in the Arboretum to
attract people to be healthy outside
and the students loved having the venue
of the Arboretum to display their art
and all of the interaction and attention
that their Works were able to enjoy from
the location
um for this last slide I also wanted to
point out the the few but very
lightweight interventions that we did do
as programs the first of which was
called chair share that's in the bottom
left
um and Haven and I actually learned of
chair bombing at a past Symposium and
immediately said that we wanted to do it
ourselves but our strategic
Communications Department on campus
didn't like the term chair bombing so uh
it was named the the program was named
chair share which has stuck and it
really works people love it it couldn't
be easier and the results from our
surveys indicate that people chose to
spend more time in nature that day
because of them and I also have pictured
here a couple of events that were billed
as nature RX events um as part of the
healthy outside campaign
and
um those were a planting event a weeding
therapy session and these were a great
opportunity for us to get much needed
work done in the garden while also
affording others the opportunity to
connect with campus nature so
start where you are use what you have do
what you can and with the power of
collaboration you're bound to be
successful thank you so much I'm going
to transition to our next speaker
Dorothy
thank you Stacy that was amazing I
couldn't keep up with all my notes
um so hello everybody my name is Dorothy
ebis I am faculty at William and Mary in
Williamsburg Virginia in the environment
and sustainability program
I regularly teach courses in science
communication GIS and ecotherapy I'm a
trained ecotherapy guide and I also run
the parks and ecotherapy research lab
this is a campus nature lab I run with a
number of very talented and passionate
students we do Outreach including Campus
Park RX and the campus green space map
and the chair bombing we also conduct
research we are currently working on two
new research projects the first
exploring the role of remotely guided
nature and Forest therapy sessions on
Place attachment mental health and
nature connection among Latino Latina
participants this is in collaboration
with Kathy wolf at the University of
Washington and tamberley Conway of
conservation connections and this one is
funded by the Association of Nature and
Forest therapy founded by Amos Clifford
the second study is a collaboration with
the William and Mary library and an
experimental psychology colleague and
good friend of mine evaluating the
mental health and productivity potential
of nature-rich indoor study and
workspaces among college students I'm
also co-writing a book called ecotherapy
with everyone with Carolyn Schuyler she
is the founder and director of Wild Rock
Nature play center if you want any more
information about this particular stuff
you can visit us at parksresearchlab.com
I can put that in the chat if anybody's
interested in that stuff because I won't
be talking about that really today
um so I'm also the co-chair of the
campus nature Rx Network with Don Ray
cow
um so before I go into my presentation I
just want to take a minute to really
thank Haven and Stacy for their
incredible work coordinating this year's
Symposium it is a ton of work
um so thank you so much for dedicating
your time to that also thanks to all of
our fellow presenters
um amazing presentations I'm so inspired
this is one of my favorite events of the
Year getting to share ideas and learn so
much from everybody in the network I'm
so excited about how this network has
grown there was four of us who kind of
chatted about this when Don ricott was
writing his book in 2019 and now we have
just this huge Network it's just
fantastic and the the creativity and the
impact is really amazing so
thanks to all of you
um again if you'd like to keep up with
the network I just want to say you can
visit campusnature.com on the home page
you can subscribe to the monthly
newsletter if you have an active campus
nature program you can complete the
membership form also on the home page
and we will make a simple website for
your program where visitors can find out
more about your program and contact you
directly we also have links on the
website to resources including Don
rickhouse framework for developing of a
new campus nature RX program so it's a
really great step-by-step guide also Don
and Laura Brown's Guide to anti-racism
in the outdoors a link to Don rickhouse
book on campusnature RX and many other
resources so
um but today I'm actually going to talk
about something different
um something
um kind of in the works uh it's a new
course I developed for this fall called
mapping for Community nature RX next
slide please
so I have to start by giving credit to
Allie Ward and her guests on andologies
podcast from August 2021 in the episode
Dr Ayanna Elizabeth Johnson and Alex
Bloomberg present this Venn diagram
approach to deciding what you should do
in this case to help save the planet
so I loved this idea simply put you make
this Venn diagram outlining one what is
the work that needs doing two what
brings you Joy and three what are you
good at so you work then with what shows
up in the middle
I applied this approach to deciding what
to do when I was asked last year to
design a new freshman course for
environment and sustainability which
integrates GIS and Alternative forms of
communication so I asked myself during
many many walks in nature one what would
be a valuable
um and and healthy educational
experience for William and Mary freshman
so normally I teach Junior and seniors
this is my first year in almost a decade
teaching freshmen
um two what do I enjoy teaching and
number three what am I good at
specifically what are my interests and
expertise and strengths
next slide please
so the course I came up with uh was
mapping for Community nature RX so the
course has five main units all informing
and culminating in a course project
which is a public-facing interactive
um esri story map that integrates Maps
videos audios images and text to share
the story of our local Green Space
support visitation particularly among
underrepresented groups
slide please
so the first couple weeks of class were
dedicated to the introduction and
background for this unit I introduced
key themes related to this topic this
integrates human environment geography
Urban Park planning and design
sustainability science communication
place-based storytelling community
health environmental justice nature and
health more broadly nature RX
eco-psychology and ecotherapy I also
introduced key theories including
attention restoration Theory attachment
Theory as applied to our attachment
specifically to Nature stress reduction
theory biophilia and nature deficit
disorder
um we had lots of pear work and small
group discussions about the themes and
theories just to get the students
thinking and talking and getting to know
each other their first semester at
William and Mary
I then introduced the course project and
the purpose of the project was to
facilitate Community Health and
well-being through nature engagement
primarily by addressing and seeking to
overcome barriers to Nature engagement
and two by increasing visitation to
local Green Space by diverse community
members through engaging inspirational
and supportive multimedia storytelling
and what I call curated Park experiences
next slide
so given the audience for our course
projects our groups underrepresented in
parks and green space we needed to
better understand why there is under
representation in the first place so we
had an in-depth deconstruction and
discussion of a research paper I
recently um co-wrote with Don Ray cow
and Chris Kim from Cornell on the
barriers to Nature engagement by one of
the most underrepresented populations
youth of color I can actually if
anyone's interested I will put a link to
this in the chat
and if you don't have access to this
feel free to um
email
[Applause]
me
that in the chat as well
so this paper summarizes some of the
literature regarding the cognitive
external psychological and social
benefits of nature engagement or time
spent in and around nature and it
highlights that there are inequitable
patterns of participation at nature
sites parks and other green spaces in
the U.S
this disparity is particularly striking
among youth of color which limits this
population's ability to gain the same
benefits of nature engagement as their
counterparts so the purpose of the study
was to better understand the barriers to
Nature engagement by youth of color by
examining intensive semi-structured
interviews of community leaders and
leaders of nature-oriented organizations
so for the course student teens were
assigned a part of the paper to read and
summarize all the notes were organized
in a shared Google doc they then shared
with the class and this led into this
really rich discussion aimed at getting
gaining a better understanding of the
key barriers that face our Target
population for this semester's course
project
next slide please
so this is a table of results from the
paper that outlines these key barriers
organized under the three main category
categories of barriers so external
psychological and socioeconomic so the
top three barriers to Nature engagement
about youth of crother across categories
were found to be a lack of accessibility
fear and social exclusion so
um if you're interested more details on
that please you know check out that
paper many students commented that this
paper and exercise was very enlightening
introducing Concepts and ideas that they
had never before considered and seemed
to be very valuable to their
understanding of the audience for our
projects namely people who are
underrepresented these places don't feel
comfortable for various reasons and how
to successfully engage them with this
project
next slide
so our second unit was study areas and
this is where we began to hone in on our
local park spaces next slide
so the course project is a team effort
so at this stage we formed student teams
with complementary skills so the team
positions include a study area lead a
field data collection lead a story map
lead and written Communications leads I
had them all sign up for something that
they felt they had some kind of strength
in and then put them together in those
groups each team then selected one of
several seven local parks to cover for
the semester and that this stage
students conducted secondary data
collection for their Parks completing a
comprehensive Park audit Forum that I
created they then orally presented their
study areas in class using shared Google
Slides presentation
next slide please
so the third unit was field data
collection
next slide
so during field data collection students
use the arcgis field maps app to collect
spatial and attribute data field notes
images video clips and audio recordings
at their park study sites data were
collected for a set of significant
natural and cultural features ecotherapy
sites key amenities trails and picnic
spots we really honed in on just a
select as opposed to mapping everything
I had them really just select the best
things to see at the park
next slide please
so uh we had a practice run on campus to
try out field maps then the students
went on Van trips to parks to collect
data for their study area
and this is a map showing the GPS data
points and lines students collected at
the seven parks and this is in the
arcgis online platform next slide please
so this is just an image of students
getting ready for their van trip next
slide
and some images from the field
from the parks they visited next please
and then we just finished recently our
cartography in arcgis online unit during
which students have been processing
their data and creating some basic Maps
next slide
so this is an example working map from
one of the groups these are really first
drafts that will be refined and kind of
reimagined for the story Maps platform
during the rest of the semester next
slide
um so this week I introduced place-based
storytelling
um the topics included an overview of
place-based Storytelling the various
points of view and storytelling and how
we can effectively communicate the
stories of our Park spaces using a
digital storytelling platform I also led
a storytelling ecotherapy exercise that
explored the Journey of a selected
natural item that they brought to class
and having them craft a story about the
places it had been and that was either
actual if they knew or imagined kind of
story of this item this natural item
next please
oh actually next slide
um we also reviewed and shared
inspirational examples of place-based
story Maps such as this one on the
voices of the Grand Canyon in the coming
week students will be integrating their
study area research their field data
their images videos and audio clips and
Maps into a story map of their own to
support visitation to Green Space by
those in our community
next slide please
so um I wanted to get a sense of how
students were responding to this course
it felt like things were going really
well but sometimes you can't tell as the
professor what exactly they're feeling
especially when they're freshmen
um they tend to not want to give you uh
feedback sometimes so last week I asked
them to fill out an evaluation form
sharing what they liked best if they had
suggestions for improvement and if they
would recommend the course to others and
I think some of these results are really
valid to what we're doing today even in
different types of programming so
overall it was very positive there was a
lot of enthusiasm about the topics and
the skills particularly the theory and
practice of ecotherapy the concept of
nature for health and well-being working
with arcgis storytelling about Park
spaces and the story Maps platform
as far as improvements they wanted more
trips to Parks material more material
kind of on all the topics and they were
hoping to get more time outside so some
of these requests are unfortunately
impossible given just the class size the
limited time in the semester and the
need for technology in this course but
these points really reflect a real
appreciation for the course themes and
the skills and I'll definitely consider
how to incorporate more of these in next
year's iteration so
um also I intentionally designed the
course with a really solid structure but
room for a bit of flexibility to remain
responsive during the semester I found
this flexibility immensely helpful and
even though it was a little bit
nerve-wracking not to have every detail
kind of nailed down but I found it was
really helpful in being able to adjust
as needed to accommodate the needs and
the interests of the students as we
moved along and so I was able to kind of
Shuffle things around just a little bit
to accommodate that one thing I was most
interested in knowing was if the
students would recommend the course to
others I'm happy to report that a
hundred percent said yes that they would
some very enthusiastically this is like
one half of the responses I love the
exclamation points and the smiley faces
here
um next slide please uh oh no sorry
previous slide
um
you know two up
sorry I think dory's looking for at
no worries
thank you so much yeah thank you so much
that what a what a course oh my gosh no
wonder everybody like 100 say like they
would recommend it to others
so uh without further Ado I'm gonna hand
it over to our next
um speakers Shane Tedder and Ashley
Hinton thank you
good afternoon everyone and Dorothy I
want to jump in that class too and I'm
going to talk about a class that I was
able to propose at the University of
Kentucky so we're we're going to talk
offline a little bit after this too
um so I'm Ashley hidden monster I am
with the University of Kentucky and as
some of you can recall 2019 there was a
call for proposals uh for A Wildcats in
the park course and so I'm going to talk
a little bit about that and I also have
with me my amazing colleague and friend
um Shane Tedder so I'll let you
introduce yourself Shane real quick
hey Ashley thank you
um happy to be back I had the
opportunity to present with this group
last year and I'm thrilled to report on
some of the progress we've made on the
projects that I introduced last year
so next slide please so when we think
back to 2019 I know this this flyer says
2022 these were actual pictures from the
course that we were able to take um in
2020 but in 2019 there was a call for
proposals a collaboration between the
university and airmark
um and for us to be able to use some of
their sites for some academic purposes
or student engagement purposes and so I
put a proposal together to teach this
nature RX course and I selected one of
the parks and they reached back out to
me and they said how does Utah and
Arizona sound and of course that sounded
absolutely amazing I was willing to go
anywhere and so a group of students was
able were able to participate in this
course
um the proposal and the call to actions
uh came about again pre-covered so
moving forward there were a lot of
delays and then I got the the Callback
of are you still interested this is
summer 21
where we want students to be engaged to
have these immersive experiences
um but there's still some some
challenges to doing so and so I was of
course willing to still move forward I
collaborated with someone out of the
College of Nursing as my role is
predominantly staff and so I put the
proposal together the call to action to
allow for the nhrx course I reached out
to um Don there at Cornell and that was
my first interaction in opportunity to
engage with this amazing group of
colleagues across the U.S and so he
consulted with me looked at the syllabus
looked at the plan said of course you'd
love to come in a non-coveted timing
um and so one day maybe that dream will
come to Patrician there but we were able
to pull in five national parks as we
were staying there in Utah area and then
we were able to go to the Grand Canyon
do some slop Canyon tours and some other
things
um in that space we did sand surfing um
of course we did a whole lot of
meditation walks um I've worked closely
with the Kuru mindfulness and meditation
so we were able to incorporate all of
those practices in it as well and the
student engagement was phenomenal they
immediately wanted to meet with the VP
as soon as we returned to make sure even
though this was a one-time call to
action that something continued around
this space so next slide please
um the course proposal again I mentioned
the syllabi worked really closely with
Don on to really how can we do this work
how do we measure it so we actually did
some pre- fitness assessment Health
assessments and then some post fitness
and health assessments we again were in
this unique time of 2021 summer where we
were still not 100 comfortable with
engagement some of the parks that we
wanted to go to especially the Slot
Canyon tours they were not open for
public so we were constantly
reevaluating and shifting our plan but
we did stay in Lake Powell Arizona and
Utah area it's right there on the line
um and since then obviously there's been
a lot of news around that space with the
the decrease in the water there but we
were able to do some kayaking and some
other Adventures while we were there
um we were able to meet with some of the
local tribes there but that was a little
bit more delicate and difficult to
coordinate student recruitment was
harder during this time again as a lot
of our International trips were getting
canceled
um so they were pushing these staycation
type trips or the stay in the U.S type
trips as opportunities and so we were
able to pick up some students from that
as well I mentioned the collaboration
between College of Nursing and so that
was also a unique uh combination of
things since oftentimes the nursing
curriculum is pretty heavy and what they
need to take in order to get through
their program so we were actually we did
not have a single College of Nursing
student participate in the course we had
non-students just using that as their
elective credit so lesson learned on
that one to be really mindful in that
that collaboration to ensure that more
students felt that they were able to
attend since then though College of
Nursing love this and supported it so
much that they have tried to work
through a similar course offering
whether it be a travel or not they're
still working through to be able to make
that part of that curriculum opportunity
for college of nursing students
um to where it would not just be an
elective but it would be something they
could build into their program also
within that space following the return
of this trip working collaboratively
with multiple colleges across the
University of Kentucky's campus other
faculty member in business and economics
and the Fine Arts and other
Lewis honors some of the other ones have
been exploring what about a general Ed
type course that all of their students
would have access to and then each of
those be whether they're around Kentucky
or if they leave and go internationally
or if they go nationally and really have
that opportunity to do so
um I think the biggest part in time I
spent on this was the adventure planning
again that timing of which were
can we get into a park do we
um is it closed because we were still
just barely opening up at this timing of
things
um we went in May
um of 20 again 21 and so
um things were shifting on a regular
basis and the only thing we did know is
we had rooms but the adventure planning
was day by day which actually ended up
being a win for I think the most
creative thing we did was sand serving
and that was just on a whim we had some
extra money in the account to be able to
pay for the students to do that
adventure and do a slop Canyon tour that
was different than the Antelope Canyon
tour that we originally had hoped to do
but that was still closed at the time we
were there and so it ended up being one
of those more adventurous things we did
that students still Rave about talk
about and still text me I remember that
time we did
um this amazing trip so
um affordability is something I was
definitely mindful of I wanted to make
it been and available to all students so
moving forward we had conversations with
our VP to talk about scholarships or
opportunities to make this more
inclusive as this was a little bit more
expensive we were still again in that
time where travel was not outrageous as
it is now because people were not
traveling as much in 2021 summer
um this trip now would probably cost
double based on the flight alone but we
were able to to do some of the things to
make this as affordable and actually our
VP put in
um several thousand dollars to cover the
expenses of the instructors and some of
those additional food expenses so
students going into it thought they were
going to be covering all of their food
but the VP actually put enough money in
to give them an allowance where they had
all of their meals covered so no
additional costs were included and that
was something that they were invested in
based on even just listening to the
students upon their return and also
seeing those results those health
results and the impact that this trip
had many of the students had never even
traveled outside of the state of
Kentucky that went with us and so this
was their first time not only doing a
travel trip of any sort but doing an a
trip with campus on campus here with
campus um people anyway
to be able to get comfortable with
leaving the state of Kentucky so next
slide there
so we did use the nature fix we also did
your Stones book there nature RX and we
had a collaboration of readings as part
of the academic component and then we
were able to pull those lessons in So
within this space they gave us a room
that Lodge of which we stayed allowed us
space to do mindfulness classes yoga
classes as well as the reading and
conversations and then we did have
assignments within this to where we
would talk about the um the chapters of
the book of which they read being moving
forward in that conversation I would
definitely be more mindful of
uh making those assignments maybe easier
to not have to submit while we were away
as
um found out really quickly internet was
not very stable where we were staying or
any of the trips of which we were on and
so oftentimes our phones alone were not
um reachable in any way shape or form
and then next slide there
so Shane I'm going to pass it over to
you so mentioning a little bit about
that class but from this class and in
some of the conversations I've been able
to have with campus Partners through
this work has really built a stronger
Network across the University of
Kentucky's nature RX initiative here
where we have a lot of those pieces of
things working they were a little bit
more siled but Shane and I have been
working timelessly to get those a little
bit more Bridge so Shane I'm going to
pass it to you now
thanks Ashley I think I've got about
three minutes and um I'll focus on just
another aspect of what I think falls
under this category of creative
collaborative collaboration and
um I showed this slide last year and
it's a good jumping off point this is
looking down from the patient Tower of
our hospital
um and a lot of the green space that you
see there is on the roof and it's there
intentionally uh visible from the
patient Tower because of our former
Executive Vice President for health
Affairs understanding that um there was
healing power and even being able to see
nature and so
um that hospital is really at the core
of a major Healthcare Enterprise for us
and that's a space that we continue to
work in to promote nature RX
and um one way that we're doing that is
to
work with a transdisciplinary team to
infuse nature RX driven guidelines into
the construction standards for capital
projects that happen on our Medical
Center and so last year I spoke about a
pilot project that was looking to
implement nature RX in a small courtyard
the I guess the design principles that
are developed as part of implementing
that project are intended to be
integrated in our construction standards
so that any Capital construction project
that happens
on our Healthcare campus and there are
several underway
um infuses uh those principles of an hrx
with it and so we're excited to be
working with several Health Care leaders
um including Dr Connie Jennings who
leads our Center for Integrative
Medicine
um and our campus planner Maureen
druckman who I believe may also be on
the call as a co-leader on that project
so we're excited to track that one as it
moves forward and hopefully scales up
the impact of that pilot
um happy to answer questions about it
and I will stop there so that we can
shift to panel and questions
um and once again Jordan Jolly is going
to help by managing the chat for
questions and posing them
to you guys are making me wish that I
could go back to undergrad this is
incredible oh I'm like okay how do I
who do I tell about this how do I get
involved
um Okay so we've got a couple questions
there's one from Catherine and it was I
believe during Dorothy your presentation
and it just says what did preferences
include
oh so that must be referring to the
research paper that I talked about the
barriers to Nature engagement
I wouldn't want to off the top of my
head give a full definition of that
category so I might have to get back to
her on that one
fair enough
um next question is I'm curious about
who signed up for the class were there
many students from underrepresented
groups did you have a sense of their
experience with the course
and I believe this was for the William
and Mary
College course
um well for my course uh yeah so I've
got actually two sections of this course
and there's 54 students across both
sections which is bigger than I designed
it for I designed it for 20 but we have
a huge incoming class right now so I
expanded it but I am yes I'm very
pleased I have there's a lot of a lot of
diversity in this class which is not
true for some of the courses I teach so
I have found that and what was the other
part of the question
um did you have a sense of their
experiences When developing the course
or with the course itself
well you know I did the best I could to
imagine again it's my first time ever
teaching freshmen to imagine you know
what you know trying to remember what it
was like to be a college freshman being
in college for the first time and and
being in a new environment
um wanting to get to know that place
wanting to get to know each other having
just a lot of uncertainty a lot of
newness
um and as far as I just assumed that
many of them would would have little to
no kind of experience having been in
natural settings or with these kind of
topics and that seems to be pretty much
the case with most the students
Ashley I know you kind of touched on but
if you want to add to that
so
um given the way this was written it was
more of the proposal idea call for
Action so not as much of an opportunity
to plan with students in mine or what
even major or college I was partnering
with as I started the process with that
um however one of the things we
definitely did encourage and discuss
moving forward if this were going to be
offered again is an ongoing opportunity
is to provide those scholarships and
those resources and partnering with
certain offices on our campus or areas
on our campus where we could get a more
diverse group of students there was a
bit of a cost to the course obviously as
we were traveling out west from Kentucky
and so that added to just a barrier to
access we did from a unique perspective
as I mentioned before have students that
had never even left the state of
Kentucky participate in this course
which is in its own uniqueness with our
with our state here
Mega is asking can you elaborate on the
gis segment I was wondering if there was
any mapping more on the social and
cultural aspects of the community along
with the geographical mapping
I'm assuming that's
directed to me for you
um yeah so uh no we didn't get into that
just because you know we kind of already
had a lot to cover and to do and I
really felt
um again thinking about freshmen and
what would be valuable for them I really
felt like what I wanted to do was this
was this is kind of like a taste tester
as kind of an appetizer of ecotherapy of
GIS of you know storytelling
um and and more than anything it was
more to kind of wet their appetite and
help direct them towards you know where
might I want to go from here and learn
more so um it's kind of like you know I
think in science communication you you
know the purpose of a piece sometimes
can be just to get people interested in
in pursuing it further and I just felt
it's so important because I had a lot of
Juniors and seniors over the years who
said I wish I would have known about
these Concepts these skills these
Technologies these practices when I was
a freshman so that's kind of where I
went with that and I love that they they
just were like we just want more like we
need to do more of all this it's great
that tells me that they are interested
so I guide them then to like other
courses where they can further develop
those skills and practices
awesome yeah sounds like you need a
whole minor just for that
um
yes
all right and it looks like uh Dorothy
also put some elaboration on the
preferences in the chat for those of you
who are interested and then we've got
another question directed towards Stacy
which is how did you actually reach the
students with the healthy outside
campaign
that's a good question
um so I'd say that the you know like via
um social media we we partnered with a
lot of
um groups on campus that did posts that
um encouraged people to participate in
the campaign
and um this swag was really really
popular as a matter of fact I was
telling some of my students about the
Sheep there was one we're going to have
a presentation at the very end by uh
Haven peers about sheep mowers so these
sheep that come and like mow our lawn in
the middle of campus and she has these
sheep mowers t-shirts and that was the
pr that was so we had like the standard
uh prize pack but then we usually had
like a featured like really nice extra
nice prize that we didn't have like 10
of for that week and my student was like
which week are you are you uh you know
like raffling off the the Sheep mowers
t-shirt because that's what I want
so basically I think just going after
the things that the students wanted
giving them the opportunity to share and
you know like so many of them are are so
accustomed to sharing their stories on
social media and photos of themselves so
it's just a really positive way for us
to channel that so I think that we kind
of uh by virtue of what we chose like
how we chose to engage people in that
participation we were able to do that
and then we uh we have certain groups in
our healthy UC Davis Network that have
list serves and um and also like groups
of students that really follow them and
we asked them to basically like share
our posts and and
um promote the healthy outside campaign
as well so that's basically what we
tried to do if that answers your
question
thank you it looks like we have a couple
more for you Stacy
um so this one is following your outdoor
challenge did the testimonials continue
beyond the 10-week campaign time frame
did it grow organ and does it still
continue to grow today yeah that's
that's true there's still you can still
submit a testimonial and people still
are submitting testimonials which is
really really sweet and the
communications person that puts them up
on the website
um we asked them you know like oh is
this too much do you want to stop and
they said that they just love reading
them so much that they love continuously
adding more and it's just
um so that web page is still live it's
the only thing that we've taken down is
all of the campaign information and the
prize packs and those rules and and uh
everything and in terms of like who did
all of the work it was it was like a
small group of Partners so so
um they're like employees in our staff
and faculty health and well-being
department on campus they work for
occupational health and there are some
of the um the leaders in our healthy UC
Davis
um group they're they're big leaders so
they were a major major help
we also have our finance operations and
administration Communications Department
we had somebody Affiliated from that
group so we're actually fortunate here
at UC Davis that our Chancellor gave
um a hundred and fifty thousand dollars
of funding
for for the healthy UC Davis Group to
continue and most of that funding goes
to actually these small Grant projects
for people on campus to do
um health and well-being based projects
and you know like everything from
diabetes to prevention to like you know
uh programs art programs targeted at
ab540 students like lots and lots of
different things
um some of it goes to supporting the
time of some of those staff people
as well but anyway so that uh that
funding also allows for that foa that's
the finance operations and
administrations Communications person to
have a little bit of funding to support
the work of healthy UC Davis so we're
fortunate that those people really
helped and then because this actually
fits pretty squarely within
um what I do for the Arboretum and
public garden as the Director of public
Horticulture and engagement I was able
to do a lot of my time you know like my
time actually went to this because it's
really trying to promote that which
we're working on promoting with it with
the Arboretum and public garden as well
thank you Stacy
um looks like we have one more for you
um could you share a little more about
what the chair share entailed
yeah so the neatest thing about the
chair share is that it's literally
buying these plastic Adirondack chairs
you need a place to store them which
luckily we have a place to store them
and we also have a way of transporting
them we have this tricycle that
um was in one of the photos
um so we're lucky to have that as well
but it's literally putting out the
chairs putting them out and we advertise
them we typically do them on Fridays
from like 10 to 2 we have student
ambassadors that put them out they don't
necessarily monitor them but sometimes
they they'll set up a table nearby we do
have some signage that says have a seat
and then it says like a little thing
like enjoy these chairs they're put here
for you to be able to take a few extra
moments to enjoy nature or something
like that
and we also have a Sacramento campus
associated with UC Davis it's our health
system campus and we have a satellite
chair share operation there
um it's just so easy and lightweight
that
um and people people really take to it
the fact that they can move things
around they can gather them up and and
meet in a small you know like a small
group or they can be off on their own we
just put it by our Arboretum Waterway
and they've just been really popular and
they're really they're really sweet
so yeah that's that's simple
I hope that helps
and we'll be starting our third and
final session Innovation through
programming and
um
our first speaker is going to be Cindy
Jones my name is Cindy Jones I'm a
faculty member in ecology and
evolutionary biology at the University
of Connecticut I'd like to thank the
organizers for inviting me to talk about
our process as we begin our real truly
what is just our second year of nature
RX programming
my motivation oh well I should back up
and say that my research focuses on
plant adaptations uh to the environment
and you can
I also put this picture in to remind
myself to tell you that I'm also the
director of our plant biodiversity
conservatory and you'll see in a minute
why that's
um relevant but my motivation for
starting nature RX at UConn is twofold
one is that you know I care a lot about
the natural world I've been studying it
my entire career
um
but the other is that I also care deeply
about my students and
so I was first introduced to an hrx or
the idea of due to Nature RX and
um
2019 and
um
I guess we'll have the next slide
I guess I I before I get to that part I
just wanted to say that
um I stumbled across this description of
the vision or the vision statement for
Parks RX recently and realize that
there's this one line spending time in
and around nature is the single most
important first step to improving both
human and planetary Health sort of
really encapsulates my motivation as I'm
sure it does for many of us at this
Symposium next slide
so I started nature RX after reading Don
Rockhouse book and I decided to approach
it basically using his guide which I
thought or their guide uh Don rachow and
Gregory Elle's books which
um
which was really helpful and so I said
about contacting people that I thought
would be interested and contacted
administrators things like that and we
had our first meeting in February of
2020 and shortly thereafter it became
very clear we weren't going to be
meeting in person anymore so we decided
instead a graduate student in my lab
um
works on uh he had done some taking some
GIS courses and he wanted to work on his
mapping skills so next slide
he and I uh decided that we would spend
the pandemic uh to the extent that we
could building a website so we also
worked with another graduate student in
our
in our department who was a website
developer and the website is here
um what Henry did was to contact all of
the local regions
um in the town of Mansfield I wanted to
focus on the town of Mansfield because
it's where UConn is and it's also a
fairly heavily wooded area UConn's a
fairly rural rural campus and so we
contacted the local
organizations that maintained Trails the
town maintains Trails the uh their
Trails through Connecticut Forest prop
or Yukon Forest property and their
trails that are maintained by owned and
maintained by a local nature conservancy
organization
and Henry acquired their math layers and
then put them all together into this
single package which we then brought up
to the website and you can see uh that
we've organized these both by both in
terms of where people might want to go
through locations and then also in terms
of activities one of the things we
discovered this was the first time
anybody had brought all these layers map
layers together and we have over 121
miles of trails just in the town of
Mansfield alone so a lot of potential
hiking places for people if they just
knew how to get there
but the other thing we acknowledged is
that people
um especially students that are on
campus for the first time and in a rural
environment for the first time may not
feel comfortable hiking and so we also
inventoried all of the quiet spaces on
campus that were places with benches
under trees and places with a view and
so if you actually want to look for
those you can go to those too
next slide
we officially launched the website at a
symposium that we time to coincide with
the Symposium last year everyone's Earth
that was also right about that time in
the fall and uh the mini Symposium that
we ran was structured so that it invited
researchers from across campus who in
One Way or Another work on the
relationship or the interaction between
humans and health and so we had speakers
from a range of departments including
natural resources in the environment and
family studies all brought together
um and then after the Symposium we
formed enough what I thought of as more
official steering committee and spent a
couple of
um meetings just talking about possible
um activities things that we could do to
launch an hrx and it very quickly
became clear uh next slide
to us that there was far more that we
could
do in terms of possibility then we could
probably actually realistically do and
it became clear also that to that we
would need a mission statement as in we
would need to figure out what our own
skills and strengths and interests were
and then Taylor whatever program we
launched accordingly and so this is the
latest statement of our our mission
statement
um and rather than focusing on writing
prescriptions because our mental health
facilities
were completely overwhelmed at this
point and had other priorities which I
totally understand we decided that we
would focus on promoting the benefits of
spending time in nature and then
developing activities for the Yukon
Community but especially for students
and then also trying to Foster
collaborations among researchers
um
next slide
one of the first things we did was to
then have a student focus group and this
was really interesting for me I'd never
done this kind of a thing we had a
facilitator from student health and
wellness who was doing an internship on
mental uh nature our accent she's the
one who facilitated it and one of the
first questions we ask is given the
pandemic and all of the media attention
to
um
the fact that nature was good for you
how how much do you feel like you guys
really understand and the answer was
pretty much across the board yeah we
know that being in nature is good for us
but we can't always make ourselves do it
right
um or that they forget to do the things
that are good for them
and the other thing that came out of
this is that because being a student
being a student comes first and then
maybe they would take care of mental
health and so they felt like we really
needed things that would emphasize
um the positive effects of being in
nature as for example students walked
across campus
um and so we talked about possibly
identifying uh these short sort of
10-minute mindfulness walks things like
that
um the students also emphasized that the
activities needed to be intentional and
Interactive
and I completely agree with that but
when I brought this back to the steering
committee the question was intentional
towards what is this intentional towards
moving your own mental health or
do we just
um
you know sort of focus on getting people
outside I mean what really are our goals
here and a group I was talking to
recently said well if you if you want to
advertise nature RX activities maybe you
could make it in terms or
package it in terms of investing in self
this is a self-investment right being in
nature is really good for you and you
will be you will benefit from it
so sort of self-care more than mental
health specifically
um
and then the other thing which has
already been mentioned is that they
suggested that rather than sort of
taking on a lot of initiatives that were
only nature RX that we would partner
with existing
um clubs and I think that's what we're
going to do as well as they suggested
that we emphasize freshmen because they
said by the time students are Juniors
they're way too busy
um and I think that's a really really
good idea
so uh with this in mind and with cold
weather in mind one of the things that
we did last spring next
was to uh jointly sponsor with the plant
biodiversity Conservatory what we call
the house plant Workshop this was just a
one day event and we had them at held it
at the greenhouses and it wasn't just a
plant giveaway which are which is always
also popular but instead
um next slide please
we
combined sort of well we had propagated
a bunch of plants in the greenhouse and
then what we did was had the staff
present basic information on how to care
for houseplants sort of think uh talking
about some of the nuances that maybe a
first-time house plant owner might not
consider like why you would choose one
type of soil or media over another how
to tell if you're over Watering your
plants why succulents are different for
example from
um
tropical plants and then next slide
after a bit of instruction we had
provided students with the plants that
we had propagated as we said they got to
choose their plants they got to choose
their pots and decorate their Pots if
they wanted to and plant them up and and
carry them out and this was really you
know most of the supplies were donated
by the greenhouses and it was a pretty
popular event but I learned a couple of
um important things from this event one
of them was that I had originally hoped
to use this event to advertise nature RX
across campus and the fact that nature
RX was holding events or co-partnering
co-sponsoring events and so we knew we
had only a limited number of slots we
set up the situation so we had 12
students come in but they had we had 12
students three different time periods so
we had a room for a total of 36 students
and we had them sign up through the
website
and all of that was I thought really a
great idea and I was hoping it would
fill etc etc and then we announced it on
the EEB greenhouses Instagram account
and all the thoughts were gone in 50
minutes so you know so much for rolling
it out to the broader Community right
that just didn't work very well
um the second thing I learned from this
is that on the day of events over a
third of the students didn't show up
even though they had signed up and so if
you do nature RX related events with
limited slot time or limited space
overbook that was the next thing that we
learned and that's what we'll do in the
future
um one of the other things that I did if
we can we go back one slide
uh oops not all uh there is it you can
see that I had uh we had designed or had
designed a uh logo by a fellow faculty
member who just enjoys designing logos
that you can see here on the left and we
had the QR code linked to our website
and I talked in the event about the
nature RX and what it meant but later in
the semester I also took the same sign
to a a tabling event uh in honor of
Earth Day and with no other information
other than the sign hoping that that
would attract students to come ask us
what it was and I just wanted to tell
you that I think we'll for those of you
who are designing logos we're going to
consider adding more explanation to ours
because most of the students who came up
assumed that we were talking about
medicinal plants or using medicinal
plants to feel better or that we were
actually talking about cannabis so again
um a lesson learned in that regard we
may change our logo a little bit
and then two slides forward okay time's
up uh I just wanted to say we're also
partnering on a project
um or an initiative called mindfulness
for Earth through our uh Global Affairs
office and I can talk more about that if
anyone's interested thank you
next slide is my acknowledgments or
supporters on campus
great thank you so much Cindy wonderful
okay so I will transition to Victoria
I um thank you for having me here and
um I am an associate professor in
Environmental Studies
um at California State University in
Monterey Bay and I'm also a co-chair of
a newly formed nature RX working group
that's part of our president's
sustainability committee
um at CSULB so um our institution is a
Hispanic serving institution roughly
half of our students our first
generation and come from
underrepresented Minority populations
and communities and we have students who
come from the central coast region where
we are in the state but also from across
California and some from other parts of
the country as well so we're considered
a destination campus and that a lot of
people choose to come to this University
because of our location
um next slide please
so um what I want to share is a little
bit about our work uh with the Living
Community challenge so the Living
Community challenge is a framework from
the living Futures Institute they
started out focusing explicitly on
buildings and fostering relationships
between people and reaffirming our
relationships to Nature through the
built environment and then they extended
that out to also focus on communities
broader more broadly speaking of how the
not just buildings but what is around
them
um through the process of biophilic
design and ideas of biophilic design and
as part of that they created a challenge
that's that our campus chose to
participate in in 2017 we were actually
the first college campus to take on the
living community Challenge and to fold
that into our planning and process
processes for campus development next
slide
so our campus was our University was
established with the closing of the Fort
Ord military base that was here in 1994
we transitioned to be a University
campus and so we were one of the largest
military bases in the U.S and so there's
there's opportunities and there's
challenges in transitioning in that kind
of land use transition so some of it's
just actual transition of buildings and
we one of the opportunities is that we
have a lot of open land and open space
on our campus next slide
so um in terms of thinking about our
campus The Living Community challenge
seemed like a great opportunity to
consider how we can really enhance
nature and nature connection not only in
the the spaces that are now part of our
campus that are natural or naturalized
but also in the buildings themselves and
we began thinking about this through
integration into an uh research methods
course that I am the instructor for and
we had students explore the campus learn
about what the Living Community
challenge is and make recommendations of
your time in the first semester that we
did this was also when we were
considering whether or not to take on
the living community Challenge and so
you can see folded into the goals that
are on the slide here
um two goals that really come from the
student's work of thinking about the
campus both from their own perspectives
as environmental study students but also
in interviewing other students from
other Majors faculty and staff and so
two key pieces of this that kind of tie
in to
um you know nature as a more of a
therapeutic and healing space and for
Renewal our ways of thinking about the
building design and connecting the
exterior natural environments through
biophilic design to the into the
interior built environments
um and then the second one and
capitalizing on both the ecology as well
as the history of the place what are
some of the things that students really
wanted to see early on and that have
become part of our campus planning
initiatives as part of this Challenge
and then also supporting
um
uh beautification through ART as well as
connections to Nature through a healthy
soil native plants and pollinators and
really emphasizing those pieces on our
campus next slide
so
um we we have continued to integrate
this work into the research methods
course every semester so now I've worked
on this over eight semesters with more
than 165 Environmental Studies students
and hundreds of students across campus
with the goal of kind of a continual
process of thinking about and evaluating
what needs to happen on our campus
what's working well as the campus
develops in areas for continual
Improvement
um next slide please
so part of the reason why I want to talk
about the class and some of the outcomes
from the class is that the process of
actually folding this into a class is
that itself provides opportunities for
nature RX through the work that the
students do so
um the way that I've approached this in
the class is to introduce students to
the idea of biophilic design we
primarily do that by watching a film
that's about an hour long on biophilic
design and what that looks like so they
start to really get a visual picture of
a variety of ways that this is both
important for health and well-being as
well as for promoting mental restoration
and learning as well as connection to
the natural environment and then some of
the vocabulary for the built environment
about how we can talk about ways that
we're seeing this on campus and then we
do a walking tour and kind of scavenger
hunt where we have a checklist of
biophilic elements and we walk around
the campus and look at sustainability
features as well as built environment a
natural environment that connect to
these Concepts
um and that in itself students say they
start to develop a real sense of pride
in their campus and they learn about
places they didn't know that existed and
so then they start to seek out and
um and kind of building on the the last
presentation kind of having their own
self-awareness and advocating for
themselves that this is actually
something that they can have ownership
of and integrate into their personal
lives as well as through the curricular
activities that we do
um in terms of methods we usually use
photovoice Behavior mapping and
interviews to gather broader start with
the cell food photo wise what do we see
that we like on campus and then
evaluating what others are doing on
campus next slide
so I just wanted to really briefly share
with you some of the the ways that
students talk about this and the slides
are broad but I'll have in my mind at
least have linkages to campus nature RX
ideas so uh what some of the pictures on
this slide
um they really like
um different
um
places for walking that we have a lot of
open space but they liked areas that
were naturalized or nicely landscaped on
campus they talked about not having
enough time to kind of go out there and
getting away so they wanted to see more
ways that the closer to campus buildings
could be enhanced they also talked a
fair amount about liking plants that
feel like other places that are familiar
to them and so one of the students in
the middle slide there with the Agaves
they they like
um they like seeing that because it
reminds them of family in Mexico and
then the third one is also a lot of
students talked about food and edible
plants on campus and ways to enhance
that both as a way to just experience
nature but also to address food
insecurity issues that are part of our
Campus Community next slide
so um I think one of the other things
that I want to kind of highlight in the
findings from some of the students is
that a lot of students especially
non-environmental studies Majors talked
about how they don't really spend a lot
of time outside but they do really
benefit and realize that they're
benefiting from the positive aspects of
kind of bringing nature natural light
views of nature into buildings
themselves and that they actually seek
out places on campus that do this well
that they recognize that it helps them
to focus to study to renew themselves
while they're working and so even for
students who don't want to necessarily
do Hands-On activities or go for walks
in nature they really appreciate the
places on campus where this is
afforded to them next slide
um so similarly
um they really like spaces that blur
kind of the indoors and Outdoors so
these were photos that students took
where they talked about
um
really
blurring the boundaries this the
photograph on the full right is one of
our newest buildings and there's this
Courtyard space it's a u-shape and they
really like that both the windows look
out onto this space that has a lot of
native plants in it as well as that
they're seating and walking areas around
this space and they they like that
concept A lot and want to see more of
that because as I said they they don't
have time to always go out and so really
folding that into the building
environment is important to them next
slide
um and then another significant piece
that I think we're really going to be
building on for the campus nature RX
working group is ways that they can be
involved in realizing sustainability
features that also our biophilic design
features on campus so
um more attention to things like bio
swells natural seating
and other forms of interaction with the
campus that can be Hands-On and
increasing the sustainability of the
campus at the same time next slide
and then the last thing I think I just
want to highlight
um is that they also really liked
physical representations of History
ecology and culture and one of the ways
that they wanted to see more of this on
campus was through murals next slide
I'm going to skip this one
um and so just uh capitalizing on the
The Living lab concept and wanting to
see more of that which I already
emphasized in the previous slide
um and then there's a question about the
green frame so sure I can answer that
while
um I'm on this slide since there's a
green frame on some of the pictures so
photovoice is a method just taking
pictures and and then having dialogue
about them and the changes that you want
to see and and having those influence
decision makers and so we do that
primarily through both inviting
um decision makers to our class as well
as sharing reports with them so we added
the green and the red frames to images
as a way of adding a layer of
communication so there's some where
there are green frames that are
indicating things that students like on
campus and then red friends are things
that they don't like on campus or that
needs Improvement I've been focusing
mostly on what they like and want in
this presentation but we have a lot of
red slides too and mostly they they look
like
um kind of the older parts of Campus
that still need more work
um next slide I think I'm almost out of
time or out of time so I just want to
wrap up that
um
we are
um
seeing the Living Community challenge is
an opportunity to explore campus
planning broadly on how to integrate
nature and sustainability into both the
built environment and the exterior
physical environment we want to inform
design principles that can guide the
whole campus planning effort
um and then also
um trying to support emergent projects
that emerged from each semester that
this happened so some of those our
students are leading a green roof and
living while independent study trying to
address more
systematically food insecurity and are
actually looking at during
beautification because those are some of
our oldest buildings on campus and so
the campus nature RX working group is a
way to actually establish
um and work across campus to formalize
some of the ideas that have come out of
their research methods course I think
that's I think next slide is my last
slide yeah so
um I see there's some questions and I
can't remember the order so I'm supposed
to answer those now or we'll we'll have
a uh
yeah okay right after we have one more
presentation
we'll address those questions so thank
you so much Victoria that was was
fantastic thank you okay perfect so
um our next speaker is going to be
having tears yeah but I'm very excited
to be here on my birthday and to share
my presentation about the UC Davis sheet
mowers with you next slide
um so just a little bit of background
about sheep mowing um basically what
this is is that uh I got excited a while
ago when I found out that they were
using sheep to mow some of the Lawns
underneath the Eiffel Tower in Paris and
I thought that that was about the
coolest thing I had ever heard in my
life and then when I realized that UC
Davis is an AG school and that we have
our own sheep Barn I made it you know my
my research agenda to um to get these
sheep mowing our our own Lawns so this
is not without precedent
um they sheep have been used to mow
Lawns
um as early as the 1850s when Frederick
Law Olmsted father of landscape
architecture designed Central Park
um it's been been he extended it when he
designed Prospect Park and then also
during the White House years in World
War one they were used as a way to show
when the men were away at war that um
you know the Sheep could do the job
um and just a good quote from from
Olmsted uh that I really like because
it's it talks about the role of of Labor
in art which I think is really important
you know and then and the importance of
Maintenance and of highlighting it not
as something that you just forget about
um you know put in your garden and walk
away but really like how do you keep
nature going
um you know so really thinking about you
know this idea of so long as
considerations of utility are neglected
or overridden by considerations of
ornament there will not be true artist
next slide
so uh my research in general focuses on
the idea on uh multi-functional
Landscapes right so I try and answer the
question how can science design and
practice converge to inform the creation
of accessible multi-functional green
spaces that maximize cultural and
environmental values
um and then you know because I love
coming up with little you know fun
mnemonics and things like that I came up
with this concept of nature heals where
heels stands for health engagement
Aesthetics labor and sustainability so
really how do we take all of these
different pieces that make a landscape a
landscape and not just focus on one or
another but really how do we create
those together and then that led into
next slide
what if
sustainability was instead sheep and so
I got really excited about this concept
and how can we bring sheep into the
landscape and all of the amazing
multi-functional things that sheep can
bring in terms of you know their
operational benefits in mowing lawns
they're educational and uh engaging in
uh aspects so cultural but also
environmental
um next slide
uh so
uh a lot of you know that I I did work
with Stacy at the Arboretum for a number
of years
um and we were an awesome team and this
concept of mowing lawns using sheep was
one that I embraced for a while before I
became um a professor and when I was at
the Arboretum and said oh I really want
to do this
um you know people tapped me on the head
and said oh that's so sweet but then I
became a fancy professor and suddenly
this was part of my uh research agenda
and so I was able to kind of push this
forward and then next slide
we have slowly been working our way on
campus so you can see our first year in
Spring of 2021 we were able to mow a
small plot of land uh kind of on the
outskirts the very edge of Campus
um you know technically still considered
campus and you know adjacent to the
Arboretum so that was good but you
really had to kind of go out of your way
to find us uh next slide
then last spring we were in a much more
Central Area I had sort of proof of
concept and so we were able to move um
to to a more Central Area
um and in front of the chemistry
building and the physics building and
and that caused a lot of a lot of
excitement and stir and then finally my
goal has been to get up to the quad
where you see those those double
um Lawns up at the front I've been told
in no uncertain terms that will never
happen
um
that there's too much uh sheep poop
involved uh and but I'm still I'm
working on it so next slide
we are getting closer so we just had a
sheep showcase last Friday
um we primarily have the sheep graze
during the Spring in the fall
um it's actually like lambing season and
it makes it crazy but we didn't want
people to forget about the Sheep um and
our program so we had them out last
Friday next slide
so basically to give a sense of
operational goals I mean just overview
of the project we bring out 25 sheep at
a time
um for three days at a time so
essentially the Sheep come out between 9
and 3 P.M every day on like a Wednesday
Thursday and Friday and they go home
every night because there's all sorts of
logistical issues
um but we have we have a fenced off area
and it's we have snow fencing and then
we have another electric fence in there
so that people really aren't around
um and and then the Sheep are there and
so we're doing research on a number of
different things right on the one hand
we're looking at operational goals right
and so how well do the Sheep manage
weeds maintain standard grass length so
we're actually like measuring those
things
um you know experimenting with low Tech
budget care you know budget lawn care
options we're looking to see whether
they're actually the cheaper fertilizing
um some of the soil and is this a way to
reduce traditional maintenance
operations on campus
next slide
and then we go into the ecological goals
where I get to put on my scientist cap
and you know really like as I said talk
about like soil nutrition right are we
adding better things are we are we
creating
um healthier soil and so we're taking
measurements before the sheep and after
the Sheep are we improving like
ecological biodiversity like is the
Sheep poop actually bringing in
beneficial insects are they helping to
remove some of the invasive weeds like
we've seen them you know eat other
things sort of preferentially things
that we don't like to you know we don't
want to we want to weed but we don't
enjoy doing it so if we can have sheep
doing it that's better
um and then can we also reduce levels of
soil compaction right because the Sheep
aren't as heavy as the lawn mowers next
slide
um but what I'm really interested in and
the and the part that I want to talk a
little bit more about are these social
cultural goals right this is kind of the
nature RX aspect of it right does having
sheep on campus on a College land-grant
University actually help enhance
place-based identity right do students
feel like they're really like a UC Davis
AG when they see the Sheep out there
does it does it make them feel is it
something that they're proud of is it
something that you know they're excited
about does it then also create these
opportunities for education and
engagement and I think it's really fun
listening to to all of these
presentations and you know talk about
Swag and talk about incentives and you
know creating succulent pots we've come
up with a whole series of different
types of things that we do with the
Sheep
um painting with the sheep or
um you know doing things like that that
I'll show you in a second
um to try and bring students in teach
them about sort of the benefits of sheep
but to do it in an engaging way so that
it doesn't feel like you know something
didactic that we're just telling them oh
this is a good for you this is
sustainable this is something that they
they maybe happen upon and they get
really excited about and then does this
help promote mental health and does it
reduce stress next slide
um so in terms of you know identity like
we've really had a great time branding
the UC Davis sheet mowers we have
um you know we have our logo that a
student created and I have to like I've
had the most amazing students work with
me
um and and it's not just because I'm in
an office right now and one of the
students is right next to me and hearing
this but I've had amazing students work
with me and we've created sort of this
identity of the UC Davis sheet mowers
and we have an Instagram account that's
there at the bottom at UC Davis
underscore sheet mowers Where we've gone
up to about 3 200 followers we've got a
website
um and really sort of created this idea
the photo on the right so we've tied
bandanas on them the photo on the right
is actually showing them they were
invited to an outdoor Gala that the
College of AG was was throwing so they
got invited to to come and participate
in a Gala so we're really trying to
integrate them into the community next
slide
um and then these are just some of the
community events and some of the ways
that we're bringing people in
um I think by far our most popular event
has been felting with the Sheep where
we're using you know wool felt and
giving people little you know balls of
felt and needles and then they can
create their own their own sheep
ornaments that they can hang or bring
with them and people love that and then
you can see one of the chair shares in
the background
um we've been lucky to be able to use
those on the days that we have the Sheep
mower event so we've got the the chair
shares and we've got umbrellas and we
try and make it like a really just sort
of peaceful but also have an activity
for people we've done planting with the
Sheep where we invited people to come
and buy native plants from uh this is
like a taco truck but it sells native
plants
um and we were actually giving out
um uh what did we call it waste wool and
so it was basically wool from the sheeps
um bottom and stomach that we're using
as fertilizer so people could add it to
their plants
um and then we've been promoting Brad
photos with the Sheep so you know again
sort of part of this place identity you
can come out and and you know get your
photos taken with the Sheep next slide
we just did with the faculty and staff
nature RX we made mobiles get it because
it's the Sheep mowers
um so we had make your own mobiles we've
done watercolors with the sheep and so
we provide watercolors and paper and you
know and the Muse is the Sheep uh and
then sheep is motivational speakers
where I'm still learning how to do this
but we we did use
um uh what's it basically stencils and
we stenciled um fun fun uh sort of
motivational things during finals week
that said you know get your sheep
together work your grass off uh wool the
wool the world
um we love our puns within the sheet
mowers and next slide
so essentially this all went along with
a mental health survey and this is where
we we basically created a survey and we
asked people at the sheet mowers event
about you know loneliness and happiness
and well-being and whether the Sheep um
made a difference and so essentially
what we found is that when we asked
people when the Sheep were around they
definitely agreed you know they felt a
lot less lonely it contributed to their
well-being all of this good stuff
specific to the sheet mowers when we
just did a comparison survey to when um
the Sheep were around and then in the
same place when the Sheep were not
around we found that you know stress
levels were approximately the same but
what we're looking at is the idea of
this momentary sort of sense of
relaxation right that it's not like
long-term affecting happiness but in the
moment it's really contributing and sort
of creating this this sense of stress or
stress reduction
um and relaxation and then we've gotten
tons of testimonials to to sort of
support that next slide
um and then this is my new favorite
thing so I discovered this app that's
like the things that you see at Ikea
where you get to press the smiley face
to talk about customer service instead
of like saying anything and so we
essentially just went up to people at
the sheet mowers events with a
smartphone and said how are you feeling
right now and they pressed the smiley
face of how they felt and then we we had
students go to the same place at the
same time when the Sheep weren't around
and ask the same question and what I
think is so interesting is that if you
look at just like the straight up happy
face it's really about the same and so
um you know great everyone's got that
same base level of happiness but then
when you look at when the Sheep are
present that extra happy is so much more
elevated than when you look at it with
the non-sheep
um and you can see with the non-chief
that you've got more non-smiley faces so
again it's supporting this idea that in
the moment it is you know this wonderful
sort of Happiness like you feel really
great about it uh next slide
so that's really all I have to say about
um about the Sheep but it's it's been a
really fun program and we I mean I
definitely say follow us on Instagram if
you're at all interested in in watching
um we have lots of puns and we do lots
of videos and we're going to be out all
spring so essentially we come out and
mow The Lawns in the same place
um once every two weeks two or three
weeks and we and it's three days at a
time so it's like a Wednesday Thursday
Friday
um and then three weeks and then and
then they come back so thank you
yeah okay
um we have a couple questions well first
of all what an awesome project such
Ingenuity going on in this group of
folks um I'm super excited to follow up
about it uh we have a couple questions
about what what is the app
um we have someone mentioned they're
happy or not machines that can upload
info on how people vote um but Haven if
you have a different app that you've
been using and you want to pop in and
mention that it's just called survey app
um and it's got two little smiley faces
on it I I yeah but you can download it
you can download it on you know in the
App Store and you can find it online but
it's not a it's a pretty generic name
but survey app
survey app easy enough
then we've got a question for you Haven
for campuses who don't have their own
sheep population what it makes sense to
bring sheep in from elsewhere
so I think so I mean I'm actually right
now talking with
um the Davis High School about bringing
the Sheep over there because uh one of
the counselors it thinks that it would
be such a great thing for her students
and so she's really excited like can we
bring the sheet mowers over and once you
know there are a lot of Hoops to jump
through so we're actually like to use
the campus sheep so we're actually going
to borrow someone's sheep for the day
for at least this pilot project to try
it at the high school to see how it
works
um but I think it's this and and it's
basically we're partnering with the the
counseling department at the high school
and the 4f
um department and so the student who's
bringing it's a former student who's
going to bring her herd of sheep that
she has she's going to be off from
college for a second uh you know during
right before Christmas break and then
she's going to bring her sheep so I say
definitely definitely bring in sheep
from other places and more and and more
we're actually seeing people like rent
out their herds for the lawn maintenance
portion of things and so what I want to
do is expand that so that it's not just
you know they're not just bringing it to
people's Lawns but they're also bringing
it places for the health and wellness
benefits
awesome
and what do you think about sheeps
versus goats for weed control
this is this is really good so uh sheep
are Grazer like cheaper browsers goats
or grazers she I don't I never remember
which one means what but what it means
is that goats pull up from the roots and
they will eat anything and so they like
they're really good for Fire Control
they're really good for just like
putting in an area where you want
everything removed sheep are a lot
pickier and so that's why we're using
them on like lawnscapes because they do
really well with just like they they are
not gonna like climb up trees they're
not going to eat wires on solar panels
they're not going to do that sort of
thing they just kind of munch and then
this is my fun fact sheep do not have
upper teeth there are no upper teeth
there so they can't yank and bite things
out they're just using those bottom
teeth to pull things so that it's much
less of an aggressive kind of thing than
a goat
Haven I have a question how much of a
factor is poop and is anybody cleaning
up the poop after a cheap grazing day so
we're not cleaning it up um we are
leaving it and we are promoting it as
fertilizer and so what we did
um between sort of grazing events last
year was we had signs up you know so we
still we left our snow fencing up but
opened it so that people could go and
sit on the grass but we had a little
sign that said Beware of poop you know
this is going to biodegrade and it's
bringing in all sorts of good things but
just be on the lookout so that's that's
how we got around with it
um for this High School event I have
signed up to show up with a pooper
scooper afterwards
so you know sometimes you just have to
sacrifice a little
thank you does anybody have any more
questions
for any of our three lovely panelists
[Music]
well if there are no more questions I
just want to give a thousand thank yous
to Stacy Parker and Haven cures for all
of their work on organizing a fabulous
Symposium today
foreign
and
um
I also wanna I wanna thank all of our
presenters too it's it's really been uh
it wouldn't have been a symposium
without their fabulous uh presentations
and
um I do
uh you know Jordan please interrupt me
if any more questions do come in
but I will say that I want to plug the
newsletter we are always looking for
um
you know ideas we want to feature the
work that you all are doing and uh
sometimes I would just say please don't
underestimate the the impact of what
you're doing even if it's a tiny program
that could be like just what somebody
needs as inspiration for getting started
it there so
um please always think about sharing
some of your program ideas with us we
typically when sending out the
newsletter there's
um
a link to a form that you fill out with
uh with the information that you want
that you know like whatever program or
project that you want to share and uh
and then some of us who work on the
newsletter will reach out to you but I
just wanted to say we really want to
hear from you because all of this
incredible work that we've been learning
about today
um it's just it's really fabulous and
it's nice to actually have this
newsletter that's uh you know like every
month learning about like little tidbits
here and there I also want to thank
um all the other people that helped
Haven and I pull this off today once
again I just really want to reiterate
that Don and Dorothy and others have had
already charted this this path for us
and made it really quite easy like
down to like six weeks before do this
you know like everything that we needed
to do so thank you so much again to them
for even putting this network together
I also want to thank my student Danielle
uh Mega and uh we also have a visiting
scholar from Brazil named Daniela who's
been helping in this effort and is
really interested in nature RX and
bringing it back to her University when
she goes back and then
um of course Jordan thank you so much
for your help and monitoring the chat
and and
um posing the questions during all of
the question and answer sessions and
Haven for being my
co-conspirator even though she's a big
fancy Professor now
we have I am just really fortunate for
these collaborations and she's one of my
favorite people to to work with and I
couldn't have put this on without her so
thank you all so much do we have any
last questions that have come in we do
we've got a question about the
newsletter which it looks like uh
Dorothy put a link to the campus nature
if you guys didn't see that so you can
join the newsletter or network and then
we've got a question that asks where and
when will the PowerPoint presentations
be posted for us to review
that's such a good question I'm I'm like
literally taking this like one little
day at a time and I'm like okay so so
we will make it a priority
yeah so um I think it'll take longer for
the recordings
um the the slides will be posted on the
website the recordings I think that
there's a way to like treat them so that
they they probably need to be closed
captioned I'm sorry that we didn't have
closed captioning today and
um Catherine thresher Carol actually
pointed that out in the chat and I was
like trying to Google on the side how to
do that but we will make sure that that
happens for uh for the reposting on
YouTube also I think that there's
something that you can do to sort of
like segment it up so that you can get
more easily navigate to like each
presentation so I don't know how long
that will take and who will do that I'm
hoping to find somebody
um who can help me to do that
but the slides I think we can probably
get uh posted pretty quickly probably
within the next week or two I would say
so
um and I'll just add real quickly that
um if you join the newsletter we will
definitely put out an announcement when
the slides are available on the website
and also when
um the videos are ready and Stacy I can
give you some advice on the videos too
very good
see I'm telling you Dorothy has been
like everything in this process
thank you
okay Jordan did we have any more
questions
no wow okay I'm gonna stop sharing I
would just like to see everybody
together if you want to turn on I mean
you don't have to but it's kind of nice
like this is our Network this is our
campus nature Rx Network and I'm sure so
many of you are doing such fabulous
fabulous work and oh it's so beautiful
to see your faces thank you so so very
much this is yes someone take a
screenshot not me because I'm not gonna
be able to figure this out
somebody please take a screenshot and uh
and then send it to us thank you all so
much for a fabulous Symposium I do hope
that we get to do this in person at some
point
um maybe we can do like a little hybrid
because I know that this this uh format
actually enables so many of us to
actually be here but I just really want
to thank you all for all of the work
that you do I feel like uh you know it's
been a privilege for me to be a part of
this community and to do this work and
to and to take inspiration from so many
of you uh really had it not started with
Don I wouldn't have
um started a program here at UC Davis
and so many of you have just contributed
all to making that bet that program
better and better year after year so
thank you all so much did anybody get a
screenshot oh we've got another person
to admit
anybody get that screenshot
nice isn't it yeah I got one yay thank
you
okay well does anybody have any final
words questions anything
we have four more minutes
I think we're good to go
okay Raven and Stacy okay thank you all
so much yeah
thank you here see you next year thank
you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu